Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft. Und ich begrüße alle hier zur 33. Ausgabe, um ein spezielles Thema einzufangen, was glaube ich hier ganz gut in diese Reihe passt und was sich so mit der Frage auseinandersetzt, an welcher Hochschule man eigentlich landen möchte. Und es ist meistens eigentlich eine Frage für Studenten, aber es ist natürlich in gewisser Hinsicht auch eine Frage für Forschende und Lehrende und insbesondere die Frage, was man eigentlich macht, wenn man eigentlich gar nichts findet, was einem gefällt. Und im Kern geht es um ein interessantes Projekt, nämlich die Cusanus-Hochschule und dazu begrüße ich zunächst einmal Silja Graupe, schönen guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Frau Graupe, ich will es mal kurz vorwegnehmen, bevor wir das Thema erst mal noch ein bisschen nach hinten schieben. Aber Sie haben eine Hochschule gegründet?
Genau, Sie haben ja gerade gesagt, was tut man, wenn man keine Hochschule findet, wo man landen will. Ganz so ist es nicht gewesen. Alle unsere Kollegen sind und waren an staatlichen Hochschulen, an privaten Hochschulen vorher. Und wir haben uns dann zusammengetan und aus diesen Erfahrungen heraus wirklich zu sehen, können wir etwas neues gründen, das viele Thematiken, viele Probleme, die wir sehen, aufgreift und ganz neu gestaltet. Und was uns vor allen Dingen interessiert hat ist dieses Zusammengehen von Wissenschaftlichkeit und Praxis, von Form und Inhalt und diese Frage, wie können wir das gestalten was wir auch lehren? Und wirklich für das stehen, für was wir in der Wissenschaft eintreten. Und haben dann vor diesem Hintergrund die Cusanus-Hochschule in Bernkastel-Kues gegründet, ein sehr junges Projekt. Wir sind jetzt erst ein Jahr staatlich anerkannt. Haben jetzt zwei Studiengänge und werden im Herbst vier Studiengänge anbieten.
Auf die Details kommen wir gleich nochmal zu sprechen. Was mich natürlich jetzt erst mal interessieren würde ist, wie es denn dazu eigentlich gekommen ist? Was ist denn Ihr Verhältnis zu Wissenschaft? Womit hat es denn angefangen?
Also ich selbst bin von Hause aus erst mal ungewöhnlich für eine Hochschule, die Ökonomie und Philosophie anbietet, ich bin Wirtschaftsingenieurin für technische Chemie. Bin also zwischen den Fächern ausgebildet von BWL, VWL, Recht und Chemie und dann technische Chemie. Und das hat mich immer fasziniert, zwischen diesen Disziplinen zu leben. Ich bin dann von der TU Berlin aus ein Jahr nach Japan gegangen. Habe ich mich mit interkulturellen Fragen beschäftigt, bin zur Philosophie gestoßen und das ist für mich eine sehr wichtige Frage, wie können wir heute verschiedene Disziplinen zusammenbringen, vor allen Dingen in der Bildung, also auch in der Lehre. Und das denke ich zeichnet mich aus, mit dem Schwerpunkt auf der Frage, wie können wir unterschiedliche Disziplinen zusammenbringen, um über große Gesellschafts- und vor allen Dingen Wirtschaftsfragen nachzudenken.
Ich würde gerne nochmal ein bisschen weiter zurückgehen. Wann war denn für Sie das erste Mal klar, dass jetzt Wissenschaft überhaupt Ihr Ding ist? War das schon immer so oder war das eine späte Erkenntnis? Gab es da irgendeinen Auslöser? Was hat Sie denn sozusagen überhaupt mit dem Gedanken erst so verbunden?
Das ist vielleicht so diese entscheidende Frage, wo ich vielleicht am Anfang gar nicht wusste, ist jetzt eine wissenschaftliche, aber diese Grundfrage, will ich etwas wissen? Und das hat mich sehr stark bewegt in der Zeit, wo ich in Japan war. Mit japanischen Wirtschaftsfragen, gar nicht so uninteressant heute, beschäftigt habe, wie entstanden Blasen? Damals waren die eher noch auf Asien beschränkt zu der Zeit.
Also solche Finanzblasen, wie zum Beispiel die Finanzkrise jetzt 2008.
Genau. Und dann zu merken, dass die wichtigen Fragen, die kulturellen Fragen, die dabei offensichtlich eine Rolle gespielt haben, dass ich die, durch das was ich bis dahin gelernt hatte in der Volkswirtschaftslehre, in der Betriebswirtschaftslehre, nicht beantworten konnte. Und das hat mich umgetrieben, warum studiere ich eine Wissenschaft, die mit einem Anspruch auf Allgemeingültigkeit, auf ein bestimmtes Wahrheitsverständnis erhebt. Und ich dann in einer anderen Kultur sehe, ich komme eigentlich mit dem was ich gelernt habe nicht richtig weiter.
Und was waren da so die ersten Erkenntnisse daraus? Also die Werkzeuge, die quasi die BWL, die Betriebswirtschaftslehre, mitbringt erklärt diese Phänomene nicht, aber man sieht, dass diese Phänomene ganz wichtig sind in diesem System, was man eigentlich versucht zu beschreiben?
Genau, also für mich war es damals glaube ich nicht so deutlich, sondern erst dieses Unbehagen zu sagen, so ich habe was gefunden und das scheint wichtig zu sein, ich habe aber keine wissenschaftliche Form, in der ich das ausdrücken kann oder die unter Kollegen oder damals unter den Professoren irgendwie akzeptiert worden wäre.
Und das war dann sozusagen der Ruf, sozusagen sich dem Wissenschaftlichen noch mehr hinzugeben als bisher schon?
Naja es wäre die eine Entscheidung gewesen, eher jetzt Richtung Japanologie zu gehen und zu sagen, ich möchte jetzt irgendwie dieses japanische System besser verstehen. Also Sprache studieren, was ich auch teilweise gemacht habe, die Kultur zu verstehen. Und ich bin aber dann nach Deutschland zurückgekehrt eher mit einer anderen Frage, was ist diese Wissenschaft selber, also diese Ökonomie? Auf welchen Voraussetzungen beruht sie und wie prägt sie und formt sie unser Denken, dass sie bestimmte Fragen nicht zulassen kann. Also ich würde heute das auch anders formulieren, dass diese soziokulturellen Faktoren von Macht beispielsweise, dass die ja in einer Wissenschaft erklärt gehören. Was sie auch in der Ökonomie tun, aber nicht in dem was ich als ökonomische Bildung oder Ausbildung eben erfahren habe. Und deswegen ist die Wissenschaftsfrage eher in eine wissenschaftsphilosophische Frage gekippt. Ich habe mich dann in meiner Dissertation fünf Jahre mit der Frage auseinandergesetzt, was sind eigentlich die Grundlagen der ökonomischen Methode und wie lässt sich das aus interkultureller Fragen stellen an Begrenztheit von wissenschaftlicher Erkenntnis.
Was muss ich mir unter „die ökonomische Methode“ genau vorstellen?
Dass wahrscheinlich eine komplexe Antwort … Also im Mittelpunkt steht erst mal die Entscheidung, die ja die Ökonomie erst im 18. und dann vor allen Dingen im 19. Jahrhundert getroffen hat. Im 20. Jahrhundert dann schon fast als gegeben vorausgesetzt worden ist, diese Idee, dass wirtschaftswissenschaftliche Methode naturwissenschaftlich oder naturwissenschaftlich angelehnt sein muss. Also eine mathematische Methode, nach dem Vorbild der reinen Mathematik und der reinen Mechanik. Das war der Ausgangspunkt zu sagen, was setzt eigentlich eine solche Methode voraus und welche Alternativen gibt es dazu, die dann zum Beispiel in der subjektiven Wertlehre zum Beispiel sind? Also dann auch ein Verständnis der Person selber erfordert bis hin eben zu größeren Fragen von Kultur, von Gesellschaft und Erkenntnis, die dann auch in ethische Bereiche gehen.
Was sind denn so vergleichbare Dinge, wie dieser Einfluss zwischen Zentralbanken und Unternehmen, der jetzt so spezifisch japanisch ist? Gibt es da auch irgendwie ein gutes Beispiel, wie man das sozusagen mit einem europäischen Kulturkontext auch beobachten kann? Also wo diese soziokulturellen Faktoren hier etwas bewirken, wo die Betriebswirtschaftslehre oder Volkswirtschaftslehre mit den derzeitig angebotenen Modellen versagt?
Also eine gute Diskussion, die zumindest immer erst mal auch auf die ökonomischen Lehrbücher zielt, also jetzt nicht auf die Wirtschaftswissenschaft, sondern insgesamt, was ich auch viel mit Studierenden durchgehe, ist eben die Erläuterung von Arbeitslosigkeit, die ja auf Faktoren zurückgeführt wird, wie man sagt von Angebot und Nachfrage. Dass man sagt, es gibt eben natürliche Bewegungen dahin. Eine ganze Debatte um Mindestlöhne beispielsweise. Und da sieht man eben auch wieder, dass Machtphänomene eigentlich komplett aus der Theorie ausgeklammert werden. Also die Frage, was passiert, wenn Vertragspartner eben systematisch Ungleichgewichte in Machtpositionen haben und wie kann das eben auch Arbeitslosigkeit oder eben Preise, also Frage von Mindestlöhnen und so weiter, beeinflussen.
Und was war so Ihr Eindruck, wie viel fehlt sozusagen dem ökonomischen Unterricht, dem VWL oder auch BWL Studium? Also sind das einzelne Aspekte, die da fehlen oder fehlt da irgendwo ein ganz fundamentaler Teil oder muss man das so sehen, dass da sozusagen alles in die falsche Richtung läuft? Wie unrund ist sozusagen das Angebot, was derzeit existiert?
Also für mich war es erst mal in der Dissertation ein Wissenschaftsproblem, also die Frage der Einseitigkeit bestimmter wissenschaftlichen Perspektiven und ich bin dann 2009 an die erste Privathochschule berufen worden und habe da dann eben auch verstärkt angefangen, mich in der Lehre zu engagieren und seitdem ist mein Forschungsschwerpunkt wirklich auf diese Bildungsfragen eher gekommen. Also nicht zu sagen, ist jetzt die eine Theorie richtig oder falsch, sondern zu fragen, wie kommen eigentlich – ja platt gesagt – wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse in Köpfe von Menschen und wie prägen sie unsere Welt- und Menschenbilder. Und in dem Zuge bin ich in der Forschung viel unterwegs, um mir eben das Phänomen ökonomische Bildung selber anzugucken. Ich meine jetzt hauptsächlich erst mal an Hochschulen. Und da sind wirklich viele Phänomene zu beobachten, wo ich sagen würde, das ist ein sehr schwerwiegendes Problem, was wir haben. Also es ist nicht einfach nur diese oder jene Ecke.
Wir haben eine ökonomische Bildung, die ab dem zweiten Weltkrieg durchgehend und dann zunehmend in den 90/2000er Jahren in einem extremen Maße standardisiert worden ist, was es für Sozialwissenschaften eigentlich nicht gibt oder selten gibt. Und diese Standardisierung geht mit einer extremen Einseitigkeit einher. Dass eine bestimmte Methode, eine mathematisch orientierte Methode gelernt wird, ohne sie aber zum Beispiel historisch einzubetten oder zu sagen, das ist eine Perspektive und es gibt andere Perspektiven. Und gerade diese Art von Bildung, die da vermittelt ist, nicht nur einseitig ist, sondern eine extreme Form der Weltferme aufweist. Also es geht dann praktisch um wirklich realtitäsferne bis realitätslose Modelle, die im 19. Jahrhundert begründet worden sind, die da auch ihre wissenschaftstheoretische Berechtigung und Positionierung hatten.
Die aber auch wieder nicht stark, also diese Weltferne nicht stark, genug sichtbar gemacht wird für die Studierenden. Und die ganze Frage, wie wirken jetzt diese Bilder, zum Beispiel einer harmonischen Wirtschaft, die dort vermittelt werden auch überhaupt nicht mit den Studierenden problematisiert wird. Man hat das ja dann 2008/09 deutlich gesehen, dass die Kritik an der Wirtschaftswissenschaft zunimmt in dieser Diskussion Einseitigkeit und Weltferne und ich finde den dritten Punkt immer wichtig, mit dem wir uns auch beschäftigen, wie kann eine weltfremde Lehre dann dazu beitragen, dass Gesellschaft sich verändert. Und eben zum Beispiel Wirtschaftskrisen entstehen können. Also wie kann was, was völlig weltfern ist oder als weltfern gilt, wie kann es wirksam werden, was passiert da eigentlich?
Was ist denn, wie muss man sich denn das vorstellen? Also wenn man jetzt so was nicht studiert hat, dann hat man ja so keine rechte Vorstellung davon, was einem dort eigentlich vermittelt wird. Also Sie sagten, hohe Standardisierung, das heißt eine Uniformität des Lehrmaterials, egal wohin man geht weltweit oder nur in Deutschland?
Es ist weltweit. Das ist das absolut faszinierende oder negativ faszinierende, dass zu uns Studierende beispielsweise aus Mexiko kommen und sagen, dieses Modul wird anerkannt, wenn wir von Mankiw, also das Lehrbuch von Mankiw irgendwie die Kapitel 1-14 irgendwie gemacht haben, und ansonsten würden sie Probleme bekommen. Also es ist eine Standardisierung, die weltweit erfolgt ist, die großen wichtigen Lehrbücher sind in 20-30 oder mehr Sprachen übersetzt und prägen eigentlich den Diskurs nahezu in allen Erdteilen. Wobei es natürlich Ausnahmen gibt.
Und warum ist das so? Ich will jetzt nicht mit Weltverschwörung kommen, aber …
Das ist eine gute Frage. Sie können einerseits auf die Frage gucken der großen Verlage, die dahinterstehen. Das ist einfach ein riesiger Markt, das ist ein Millionen, wahrscheinlich Milliarden schwerer Markt. Das wäre eine Seite. Die andere Seite ist, dass es natürlich eine sehr leichte Form der Vermittlung ist. Also die Frage, warum nimmt jeder Dozent, warum übernehmen wir das? Wir haben gerade neue Umfragen gesehen, dass vieles an ökonomischer Lehre sozusagen prekär unterrichtet wird von Menschen, die wenig Geld dafür kriegen, die nur einzelne Semester oder semesterweise angestellt sind oder sogar nur einzelne Lehraufträge bekommen. Und diese Art der Lehre in dieser Standardisierung heißt, die ist unheimlich gut vorbereitet, es gibt alle Antwortbögen, es gibt alle Klausuraufgaben. Es gibt PowerPoint-Folien und so weiter, so dass da auch auf eine Standardisierung unter den heutigen Bedingungen der ökonomischen Bildung, was nachher auch wichtig ist, also ökonomisierten Bedingungen natürlich auch durchschlagend ist.
Das andere, mit dem wir uns viel beschäftigen, ist die Frage politischer Wirksamkeit. Also gibt es Einflüsse zum Beispiel von Thinktanks, von Standardisierungs-Institutionen, eben eine bestimmte Form der Bildung zu propagieren, um schlicht und ergreifend Fragen auch aus der Gesellschaft auszublenden oder Menschen nicht mehr zu motivieren, diese Fragen zu stellen. Das ist ein schwieriges Feld. Das eine ist sozusagen, das nachzuweisen, gab es diesen Willen? Sie sagten ja, Verschwörung. Und das andere in dem Feld, wo ich mich eher bewege, weil ich dafür sozusagen nicht die Zeit und die Mittel habe, so was nachzuweisen und zu sagen, wie wirkt das tatsächlich? Um den Einzelnen zu befähigen, auch Entscheidungen zu treffen, sich anders bilden zu wollen, also eine andere Alternative zu gehen, indem er woanders studiert oder sich eben für ein anderes Studium dann entscheidet.
Ich meine die Wirtschaft ist ja ohnehin gerade auch so global stark unter so einem Standardisierungsdruck einfach um sich selbst zu organisieren, weil sie ja irgendwie feststellt, wenn wir eingespielte Methoden haben, eingespielte Modelle haben, eingespielte einheitliche Ausbildungssysteme auch haben, wie wir das jetzt auch mit dem Bologna-Prozess sozusagen nochmals verstärkt bekommen haben, na dann ist das ja sozusagen für uns einfacher. Ist das quasi so dieser kleine Holzweg, auf den sich dann alle auf einmal begeben haben und sozusagen so eine Einheitssicht der Dinge sich durchgesetzt hat?[00:15:57-2 @siljagraupe>Also der eine Aspekt, ich sage mal das trifft die ökonomische Bildung doppelt. Einerseits gibt es diese Ökonomisierung von Bildung und dann gibt es diese Einseitigkeit innerhalb der ökonomischen Bildung. Und die Ökonomisierung von Bildung, Sie sagen das Stichwort Bologna, die trifft ja im Moment alle Studiengänge. Und jetzt auf diese allgemeine Schiene gesprochen, ja es gibt dadurch klare Vorteile. Also zum Beispiel wenn man eine mathematische Sprache durchsetzt, dann kann man sich international irgendwie verständigen und andererseits wird hier ein wesentlicher Bildungsaspekt vollkommen ausgeblendet, dass es hier ja darum geht, eine schöpferische Vielfalt für eine junge Generation zu vermitteln, die Fähigkeit zu vermitteln, Fragen zu stellen und auch immer wieder den eigenen Horizont zu erweitern, um diese Fragen bewegen zu können. Und jetzt insbesondere gesprochen auf die ökonomische Bildung auch andernorts, wenn nur ein einziges Set von Denkwerkzeugen vermittelt wird, dann passiert das, was ich eine geistige Monokultur nenne.
Die riesige Schwierigkeiten oder eine riesige Gefahr hat, dass diese Monokultur einfach unglaublich anfällig wird. Und das geht, also eine solche Monokultur geht einher mit einer abnehmenden Fähigkeit der Kritik und der Möglichkeiten eben anders zu denken. Und jetzt ist natürlich eine Grundfrage, für was steht Universität? Was soll Hochschule? Und unter dem Stichwort Bildung vs. Ausbildung oder durch andere Schlagworte sieht man ja, dass nur die Vermittlung eines festen Werkzeugsets oder eines Gedankeninstrumentariums nicht das sein kann, was eigentlich eine Bildung, eine akademische Bildung ermöglichen soll.
Jetzt kommen wir so langsam auf den Punkt. Weil was ich jetzt bisher raus gehört habe ist ja im wesentlichen erst mal eine Betrachtung also nicht einer einzelnen Disziplin, aber sagen wir eines bestimmten Teilbereichs. Ökonomie, Wirtschaftslehre, Betriebswirtschaftslehre, Volkswirtschaftslehre, also im Wesentlichen halt so der Blick auf die wirtschaftlichen Prozesse unserer Gesellschaft im engeren und im weiteren Sinne. Deswegen gründet man ja nicht gleich eine neue Hochschule, also vielleicht eine Wirtschaftshochschule könnte ich mir vorstellen. Inwiefern gibt es denn – vielleicht ist es ja auch gar nicht so – aber gibt es denn sozusagen eine ähnliche Feststellung auch in anderen Disziplinen? Dass sozusagen diese entweder so ein Drang zur Standardisierung oder irgendeine anders geartete Engstirnigkeit da einfach ein Mangel an Innovation mit sich bringt, der auch andere wissenschaftliche Themenfelder betrifft?
Also das zweite große Fach, was wir dabei haben, ist die Philosophie, die bestimmt nicht so stark eingeschränkt ist oder so einen starken Lehrkanon hat, wie das in der Ökonomie ist, wo wir aber auch da sehen, dass ganze Bereiche der Philosophie immer weniger gepflegt werden und der zunehmenden Dominanz der analytischen Philosophie und auch da ist es uns eben wichtig zu sagen, bestimmte Fähigkeiten, also Fähigkeiten Fragen zu stellen, Fähigkeiten sich selbst zu bilden, Fähigkeit Verantwortung zu übernehmen, Entscheidungen zu treffen, dass auch da die Philosophie in dem Sinne eine kritische Stimme für die Gesellschaft zu sein, dass sie das in der Bildung eben auch nicht mehr oder nicht mehr überall erfüllen kann. Wie gesagt der andere Bereich ist diese Frage, Ökonomisierung von Bildung insgesamt, die ja eher die ganze Form, also ganze Struktur, ganze Organisation der Bildung trifft. Und das führt dann schon eher in die Frage, die Sie gestellt haben, warum gründet man eine neue Hochschule?
Und das scheint uns wichtig zu sein. Gerade in einer Zeit der starken Veränderung, der Ökonomisierung, der Verwertbarkeit von Bildung, zu sagen, welche Form der Struktur innerhalb der Studiengänge braucht es, aber auch jetzt Finanzierungsfragen, Rechtskonzepte, die Frage der Stärkung oder Wiedererstarkung der Autonomie einer Hochschule, also Selbstverwaltung, Selbstbestimmung, dass das eben nochmal wie in einem Gesamtexperimentierfeld dann nochmals gestellt werden muss.
Aber wie kam es denn überhaupt dazu? Ich meine, Sie waren in Japan, dann in Deutschland, Dissertation wurde geschrieben, dann gab es eine Tätigkeit an einer privaten Hochschule, was war das für eine?
Die Alanus-Hochschule.
Wo?
In Alfter bei Bonn.
Und was würden Sie sagen sind so im wesentlichen die unterschiedlichen Merkmale von privat geführten Hochschulen und staatlich finanzierten und geplanten, strukturierten Hochschulen? Kann man das so pauschal sagen oder gibt es da Auffälligkeit?
Also ich denke, was für uns wichtig ist, dass es eigentlich drei verschiedene Formen gibt, von denen die eine Form im Moment eben nicht besonders gepflegt ist, weswegen wir da auch reingegangen sind. Sie haben einerseits die staatlich organisierten Hochschulen, die ja auch oft unter dem Stichwort irgendwie der Massenuniversitäten firmieren, also das ist der eine Bereich, den kann man sich dann noch genauer angucken. Der andere Bereich der privaten Hochschulen ist der, der unglaublich stark ist, wo finanzielle Interessen dahinterstehen. Also die eher vom Markt her sozusagen dominiert sind. Das können Hochschulen sein, die schlicht und ergreifend mit Bildung Geld verdienen wollen, also eine bestimmte Rendite anstreben. Das dürfte langsam, ich habe die Statistik nicht genau, aber die meisten in Deutschland sein an Privathochschulen. Dann gibt es welche, die ein ideelles Interesse haben oder wirtschaftlich motiviert, dass sie eben bestimmte Ausbildungen sicherstellen wollen, sei es in der Pflege, in der Medizin, in der Logistik.
Und dann gibt es diesen kleinen Bereich, der eben in Deutschland im Moment relativ wenig stark ist, was man akademische Selbstgründung nennt. Also wo der Ursprung der Idee ist zu sagen, wir als Kollegen, als Studierende, als Bürger haben eine bestimmte Vision von Bildung und wir wollen dafür Verantwortung übernehmen. Also jetzt nicht in einer einzelnen Lehrveranstaltung und nicht in einem Lehrbuch und nicht für ein einzelnes Modul, sondern wir wollen eine Organisationsform schaffen, die unserer Bildungsidee sozusagen gerecht wird. Und in diese Kategorie der akademischen Selbstgründung fällt die Cusanus-Hochschule und ist damit zumindest für die letzten Jahrzehnte ziemlich alleine, wenn nicht die einzige.
Aber was war denn so der Tipping-Point, wo so die Idee aufkam, so wie die Dinge laufen, entwickelt sich das nicht so, wie ich mir das vorstelle. Wann kommt man denn sozusagen auf die Idee, daraus so ein komplettes Hochschulprojekt werden zu lassen?
Also für mich waren viele Faktoren entscheidend, die Verantwortungsfrage. An der Hochschule, wo ich vorher war, hatte ich die Freiheit, Volkswirtschaftslehre so zu unterrichten, wie ich das für richtig und sinnvoll halte, auch unter starker Zustimmung der Studierenden. Und dann hat man eben eine Verantwortung erst mal für ein Modul oder für einen Teil eines Studiengangs und dann merkt man, die Studenten kommen ins Fragen, sie kommen ins Denken, man merkt, sie wollen große Wirtschaftsfragen bewegen. Und das Ganze quillt sozusagen über die eigenen Veranstaltungen hinweg und die Studierenden gehen woanders hin und sie wollen jetzt Hochschule mit gestalten, aufgrund eines Unterrichts, der Gestaltungsfragen thematisiert oder sie fangen an, weitere Fragen zu stellen an Voraussetzungen von Wissenschaft und ähnliches. Für mich war die Frage, kann ich das verantworten, wenn es das Umfeld dafür nicht gibt?
Also wenn schon der nächste Kollege irgendwie diese Fragen nicht aufgreift oder sogar zurückweist oder wenn es eben Hochschulstrukturen, sei es staatlich oder sei es privat, die auf diese Gestaltungsanfragen von Studierenden überhaupt nicht reagiert. Und da zu sehen, wie können wir jetzt eine gesamte Hochschule bilden, die in gewisser Weise diese Verantwortung für lebendige Strukturen, für dynamische Strukturen, für gestaltbare Strukturen eben mit übernimmt.
Das heißt, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, es geht gar nicht mal nur darum, was andres zu erzählen und einfach einen anderen Lehrplan zu haben und sozusagen das ökonomische Kleid etwas anders zu dekorieren oder das Bildungskleid sozusagen anders zu dekorieren, sondern darauf systemisch zu antworten und dass man sagt, okay wir bringen euch jetzt hier – salopp gesagt – ein wenig Revolution bei, aber wir müssen auch die Strukturen schaffen, um das was das auslöst dann auch aktiv mit einzubinden?
Ja also es ist die Möglichkeit, Strukturen zu geben, um auch wirklich zu sehen, wie weit die eigenen Ideen tragen, also nicht zu selten wird ja auch einer Wissenschaft vorgeworfen, dass sie völlig weltfremde Ideen rüberbringt, die sich dann nicht realisieren lassen. Und jetzt zu sehen, dass ich mit einer bestimmt in den Wirtschaftswissenschaften einigermaßen ausgewiesenen kritischen Haltung eben auch zeigen kann, aber ich nehme Verantwortung für eine Struktur, das ist ein staatlich anerkannter Rahmen, in dem ich das mache, und damit wandelt sich sozusagen auch diese Struktur selber. Also das was wir tun ist nicht irgendwie eine Spinnerei außerhalb der Wissenschaft. Es ist auch nicht strikt in dieser Wissenschaft, sondern die Cusanus-Hochschule probiert immer wieder aus, zum Beispiel ist das jetzt akkreditierungsfähig oder ist das nicht akkreditierungsfähig. Ist es etwas, was gesellschaftlich so vermittelt wird, dass Menschen bereit sind, dafür Geld zu geben und zwar aus Freiwilligkeit und nicht vermittelt jetzt über Steuern, wo sie das gar nicht wissen oder aus einem eigenen Privatinteresse, wie das bei marktwirtschaftlich orientierten Hochschulen dann ist.
Und für mich ist wichtig diese Mischung zwischen Beliebigkeit zu vermitteln irgendwie, auch in gesellschaftlichen Visionen, Sie sagten jetzt ja irgendwie, was hatten Sie gesagt, Revolution? Sondern auch zu sehen, was heißt es tatsächlich in einem gegebenen Rahmen, einem gesellschaftlich organisierten Rahmen so zu wirken, dass man sich selber Freiheiten schaffen kann und gleichzeitig auch sieht, dass Struktur und Ordnung Institutionen sich eben auch mit verändern können.
Aber was war denn jetzt sozusagen der Punkt, an denen Ihnen klar war, so geht es nicht weiter, man muss jetzt genauso eine Struktur, die die eigene Verantwortung auch mehr mit betont und rüberbringt, auch tatsächlich gründen?
Also interessant ist es, dass es keine Idee eines einzelnen gewesen ist. Sondern dass wir von Vornherein mehrere Kollegen, also bestimmt im engsten Kreis fünf und dann deutlich mehr sozusagen drumherum, je nach Zählung und je nach Moment dieser Gründungsphase. Und dass es immer wieder dieses gemeinsame Gespräch war, einerseits nach der Möglichkeit, also ist das möglich und andererseits wie Sie ja eben fragen nach dieser Notwendigkeit. Vorausgegangen ist der Cusanus-Hochschule 2009 die Gründung der Kueser-Akademie Für europäische Geistesgeschichte, die schon sich die Frage gestellt hat, was brauchen wir für einen Rahmen für eine freie Forschung und dort eben dann einen Rahmen, einen Ort geschaffen hat für jetzt mittlerweile über 100 akademische Mitglieder, sich für akademische Forschung, für akademische Bildung und für gesellschaftlichen Dialog zu treffen und zu arbeiten.
Was sehr erfolgreich gelaufen ist, auch an dem Standort von Bernkastel-Kues sozusagen also der Gründungsort, und in dem es dann immer sehr viele Gespräche und auch eine sehr große Arbeit an dem Bildungsbegriff gegeben hat. Immer wieder mit der Frage, braucht es jetzt nicht nur in der Forschung, sondern auch in der Lehre einen solchen neuen Ort? Und ein wesentlicher Punkt ist dann, bin mir jetzt von der Jahreszahl irgendwie nicht ganz sicher, aber so zwischen 2012/13, dass dann Studierende zu der Initiative dazugestoßen sind, die sich schon für eine alternative ökonomische Bildung, aber auch in der philosophischen Bildung engagiert hatten und uns dann auch diesen Mut und diese Überzeugung gegeben haben. Das ist nicht nur meine Erfahrung an 2-3 Hochschulen, sondern es ist jetzt eine bundesweite Bewegung, wo jetzt junge Menschen keine Orte mehr finden, wirklich mit ihren Fragen, gerade ihren Wirtschaftsfragen, in der Bildung aufgenommen und weitergeführt zu werden.
Das heißt im Prinzip dieser Verein, diese Kueser-Akademie stand so ein bisschen am Anfang der Bewegung?
Sie stand am Anfang, aber sie nicht dafür gegründet. Also es gab diese Frage, eine alternative Hochschule. Dann kam natürlich dazu, dass Kollegen wie ich auch eben an Privathochschulen tätig waren, die auch – also Alanis-Hochschule war auch erst 2002 gegründet oder staatlich anerkannt – so dass wir den ganzen Anerkennungs-, Akkreditierungsprozess auch gesehen hatten. Also dass man einfach sieht, was ist möglich. Und wir damals zumindest auch, dann wurde es stückweise immer mal ein bisschen härter, eben auch diese Gewissheit hatten oder diese Sicherheit, dass es ein Unterfangen ist, was machbar ist und das letztlich auch politisch durchsetzbar ist.
Aber trotzdem ist es ja noch eine relativ junge Bewegung auch dieser Verein seit 2009?
Ja genau, 2009, wie gesagt nach Zählung, weil man nicht weiß, wann ist so die erste Idee, lass mal eine Hochschule gründen und wann kann man auch wirklich von der Vision sprechen, kann man von einem Konzept sprechen. Aber insgesamt wird das so ab 2012/13 losgegangen sein, die ersten Gespräche mit dem Land, was ja staatlich anerkennen muss. Dann 2013/14. Und der Antrag dann zur Prüfung der staatlichen Anerkennung, was verschiedene Institutionen dann berührt, das war dann 2014. Und 2015 dann das grüne Licht von Rheinland-Pfalz eben diese Hochschule anzuerkennen.
Jetzt ist ja der Name des Ortes gefallen. Also Kueser-Akademie, Bernkastel-Kues, ein Ort in der Nähe von Trier kann man sagen?
Genau.
Da gibt es ja einen Namenspatron, den Nikolaus von Kues, auf den sich jetzt auch dieser Verein und auch die Schule beruft. Wer war das und welche Rolle spielt der hier in dem ganzen Zusammenhang?
Also Nikolaus von Kues ist eben nach der Stadt benannt, in der wir das Ganze aufgebaut haben. Für uns ist diese Verbindung zwischen Kulturregion und Stadt und Nikolaus von Kues eben wichtig gewesen. Wir werden oft gefragt, ob wir was mit dem Cusanus-Werk zu tun haben und damit also die Frage, ob wir einen katholischen Träger haben. Das haben wir nicht, also wir haben keinen Großinvestor, wir haben keinen staatlichen Hintergrund, wir haben aber auch keinen kirchlichen Hintergrund, sondern es ist wirklich eine freie Initiative.
Man muss dazu sagen, Cusanus ist sozusagen die latinisierte Schreibform desselben Namens?
Genau, also wir haben Nikolaus von Kues, oder Nikolaus Cusanus, das beides meint den gleichen Herrn. Und natürlich haben wir aber über die Nähe zur Stadt hinaus haben wir den Namen jetzt nicht ohne Bedacht irgendwie gewählt. Vieles was wir in der Philosophie machen, was wir in der Geistesgeschichte machen, beschäftigt sich mit diesem Zeitraum, also ich rede jetzt so vom 15. Jahrhundert mit Nikolaus von Kuhs und mit der ganzen Frage, was dort damals passiert ist. Nikolaus von Kuhs ist ein Theologe, Philosoph auf der einen Seite, auch Universalgelehrter, er ist aber auch Diplomat und er ist derjenige, der tatsächlich weltliche Dinge gestaltet. Zum Beispiel ist sehr beeindruckend, wenn Sie nach Kues reinkommen, dass dort ein Stift steht, dass er noch zu Lebzeiten gegründet hat und dann nach seinem Tod vollendet worden ist.
Es ist das erste, was für Altenpflege zuständig ist und zum Beispiel Einzelzellen hat. Also es ist ein Gesamtbau, aber der Einzelne wird jetzt im 15. Jahrhundert als Individuum angesprochen und er soll in Gemeinschaft aber als Individuum leben. Und der Nikolaus hat sich damit sehr viel beschäftigt, mit dieser Frage von Individualität, Kreativität, die aber immer in soziale Gemeinschaft eingebettet bleibt. Und er hat dafür Strukturen geschaffen, die über 500 Jahre gehalten haben. Also sowohl weltliche Herrschaft als auch kirchliche Herrschaft überstanden hat und die heute noch nach seinen Statuten sozusagen leben und funktionieren können.
Das ist im Rahmen dieses Stiftes?
Ja genau. Und das ist das eine, wenn man fragt, warum dieser Namensgeber? Also diese Verbindung von Wissenschaft und Praxis, was so funktioniert, denn diese Frage von Individueller Bildung in Gemeinschaft, also diese Frage Persönlichkeitsbildung, was viel mit Kreativität zu tun hat. Und dann hat er noch eine wunderschöne Figur geschaffen, das ist der Laie, das ist nicht mehr der Wissenschaftler oder der Theologe, der vernünftige Sachen oder über die Welt nachdenken kann, sondern er entwirft so eine Figur des Löffelschnitzers, der da seinen Löffel schnitzend über die Welt nachdenkt und auch wirklich zur Erkenntnis kommen kann. Und das sind einige wenige Denkfiguren, das können wir jetzt noch viel weiter ausführen, die uns dazu bewogen haben, diesen Namenspatron sozusagen zu wählen. Und dahinter steckt, dass wir gerade viel in der Philosophie eben auch eine Cusanus-Forschung tatsächlich an der Hochschule haben.
Also die sich mit der ganzen Zeit und mit ihm und mit seinen Editionen und seinen ganzen Schriften beschäftigt.
Das ist ja naheliegend. Nicht dass man nochmal irgendwas entdeckt, was nicht passt.
Genau, also das finde ich auch interessant, das ist jetzt nicht, dass wir sagen, wir heben den jetzt auf so ein Schild und das ist irgendwie unsere Leitfigur, sondern das ist auf jeden Fall auch eine streitbare Figur. Gerade dadurch, dass sie im Weltlichen gewirkt hat, sind da bestimmt auch wieder Entscheidungen immer als Kardinal gewesen, wo man jetzt nicht sagen kann, das finden wir alles gut. Aber wie ich vorhin sagte, das scheint uns auch wichtig zu sein, wirklich Menschen in ihren Entscheidungssituationen und in den strukturellen Zusammenhängen auch zu sehen und dieses Wirken auch zu erforschen und auch in dem Sinne zu akzeptieren. Auch wenn wir es in einer Reinheit der Lehre vielleicht nicht immer der richtige Weg sein mag.
Also eine Orientierung sozusagen an dem philosophischen Werk, aber jetzt nicht so eine Führungsfigur, wie man sie vielleicht bei Rudolf Steiner oder so was?
Nein, und es muss auch nicht jeder Nikolaus von Kues lesen und schon gar nicht wenn erst ich bei uns bewirbt und auch sonst nicht. Ja ich meine andere Hochschulen haben ja auch einen Namensvetter und da spielt das gar keine Rolle. Ich würde sagen, bei uns ist das eine Mischform. Also es ist auf jeden Fall nicht wie der Säulenheilige, sondern es geht uns eher darum, zu sagen, es gibt bestimmte Bildungsideen, die in dieser Zeit aufkommen, die dann natürlich nochmal bei Humboldt und so weiter stark gemacht werden und die heute einerseits unter Druck stehen, also praktisch abgeschafft werden mit diesem Leitmotto, Humboldt ist tot und andererseits auch einer gründlichen Neuentdeckung, Neuaufbereitung und Wiederbelebung auch bedürfen. Weil wir heute andere Verhältnisse haben als damals.
Was sind denn das jetzt für Leitmotive, die Sie im Wesentlichen jetzt voranstellen würden, wenn es jetzt um die konkrete Idee der Gründung dieser Hochschule ging? Also es war ja sozusagen ein gewisses Defizit sozusagen in der Art und Weise wie man arbeiten kann oder auch vielleicht in der Art und Weise wie sich Studenten in die Lehre selber auch einbringen können. An dem Punkt, wo sozusagen jetzt diese Erkenntnis reifte bei allen Beteiligten rund um diesen Verein, auch wirklich zu sagen, okay, das was wir jetzt hier eigentlich anstreben, können wir am besten eigentlich in einer komplett eigenen Hochschulstruktur erreichen und den wie ich vermute ja nicht ganz einfachen Schritt dahin, das zu machen, dieser Aufwand lohnt sich. Was sind denn so die Leitmotive, die Sie sagen würden, die jetzt quasi diese Cusanus-Hochschule konkret ausmachen?
Also was ist sozusagen das Designziel gewesen in Hinblick auf diese neue Entität? Was sollte sozusagen diese Hochschule leisten oder verkörpern, was jetzt so bei anderen Strukturen nicht da war?
Also wenn Sie auf die Strukturen kommen, dann denke ist so eine der wichtigen Sachen, wie wir es im Moment ausdrücken, zu sagen, wie kann Bildung Teil tatsächlich der Bürgergesellschaft sein. Bürgergesellschaft heißt selbstbestimmt, selbstorganisiert und das nicht in Beliebigkeit, sondern konsequent am Allgemeinwohl ausgerichtet. Der staatliche Sektor ist damit sozusagen immer schon erst mal raus und auch ein reines Gewinninteresse oder ein reines Selbstinteresse einer Gründung ist damit sozusagen unmöglich gemacht. Also das ist für uns wichtig. Und dann zu sehen, wie kann man in Bildung Selbstbestimmung, Selbstorganisation wie lässt sich das tatsächlich umsetzen? Also wenn Sie zum Beispiel, wo wir vielleicht noch drauf kommen, eben bei der Frage der ganzen Rechtskonstruktion, also was ist jetzt eine solche Hochschule? Dann ist in Deutschland immer völlig klar, eine Hochschule besitzt sich nicht selbst, sondern sie hat eine Trägerstruktur darunter.
Was auch schon den Wissenschaftsrat und andere dazu veranlasst hat zu sagen, dann haben Sie immer dieses Problem des Durchregierens, also wenn Sie immer jemand anderem gehören, dann ist immer die Frage, was derjenige, dessen Besitz oder Eigentum Sie sind, eben zu sagen. Sei es jetzt irgendwie untergeordnete Stiftungen, die also drunter sitzen oder sei es der Staat. Also das scheint uns eine wichtige Frage zu sein, die dann eben auch wieder in diese Finanzierungsfrage geht. Also wenn Sie selbstbestimmt, selbstorganisiert sind, dann haben wir wie andere Teile der Bürgergesellschaft natürlich auch die Frage, von wem bekommen Sie das Geld? Also wer versteht das, dass Sie diese Art von Unabhängigkeit brauchen? Auf die Hochschule selber gesprochen ist dann eben auch wieder die Fähigkeit und der Wille vor allen Dingen jetzt von den Kollegen, aber auch von den Studierenden, tatsächlich Verantwortung übernehmen zu wollen und zu können.
Wenn Sie heute auf staatliche Hochschulen gucken, sie es unter den Hochschulfreiheitsgesetzen oder auch noch unter einem anderen Namen, dann wird ja die Autonomie derjenigen, die eigentlich das akademische Geschäft machen, konsequent beschnitten. Also früher hatten sie alle Entscheidungen beim Senat und beim Präsidium und heute über Hochschulräte und ähnliches wird ja diese Autonomie immer weiter beschnitten. Im privaten Bereich haben Sie immer wieder Probleme, dass ein Senat zum Beispiel noch nicht mal den eigenen Präsidenten oder den eigenen Kanzler bestimmen kann. Und auch hier für uns wieder, was heißt es uns Akademiker selbst zu befähigen, die Entscheidungen, die uns angehen, auch tatsächlich treffen zu können.
Also so eine Selbstverwaltung im Prinzip?
Und auch eine eigene Trägerschaft.
Ja genau.
eine Eigenträgerschaft, die ja auch immer dann, dadurch dass sie ja in die Gesellschaft reinwirken müssen, also eine Bürgergesellschaft oder ein Akteur in der Bürgergesellschaft muss ja immer vermitteln den Sinn, also was man dort macht. Also es ist nicht unbedingt ein Zweck, aber die ganze Frage der Sinnhaftigkeit und in die Verantwortung stellen wir uns eben auch. Also wenn wir nicht klarmachen können, warum gibt es uns, wozu braucht es uns, dann würde die Unterstützung aus er Bürgergesellschaft sozusagen abnehmen und dann werden wir auch verschwinden und verschwinden müssen. Ja und das heißt also auch immer wieder zu sagen, also selber jetzt über Bildung, über unsere eigenen Vorstellungen, über die Bildungspolitik in Deutschland und darüber hinaus aufzuklären, um immer wieder deutlich zu machen, warum braucht es uns eigentlich? Wenn Sie weite nach den Visionen fragen, dann kann ich sagen, das ist jetzt sozusagen der Boden, auf dem einerseits eine unabhängige Forschung entsteht, die sich tatsächlich mit Gesellschaftsfragen auseinandersetzt.
Und der zweite und eben auch wichtige Punkt, Forschung hätte man auch woanders machen können, ohne eine staatlich anerkannte Hochschule zu haben, ist eben die Lehre. Und wirklich zu sagen, wie können wir heute Persönlichkeitsbildung in Verantwortung für Gesellschaft und Gemeinschaften tatsächlich ermöglichen.
Also sozusagen, wenn ich es richtig verstehe, Ziele sind a) eine gewisse Unabhängigkeit selbstverständlich, aber dann vor allem auch so mit diesem Charakter der Selbstverwaltung. Das heißt der Träger ist sozusagen man selbst, heißt das dass es dann so ein demokratisches Prinzip gibt, und alle Lehrenden sind sozusagen auch ihre eigenen Träger?
Das mit der Rechtsstruktur ist sozusagen noch ein bisschen komplizierter.
Aber jetzt erst mal zu den Zielen nochmal und eins der Ziele ist quasi, einen eigenen Forschungsbetrieb aufzumachen, der quasi unabhängig von etablierten Denkprinzipien anfängt, sich die Gesellschaft vorzunehmen.
Also Unabhängigkeit nicht im Sinne von jetzt, wir wollen keine Wissenschaft oder wir einigen uns nicht auf wissenschaftliche Prinzipien, aber die Freiheit, vorher sprach ich von dieser Einseitigkeit und dieser Fixiertheit beispielsweise auf bestimmte Methoden. Und da jetzt zu sagen, wir wollen diese Freiheit entwickeln einer Methodenwahl und auch eine Freiheit einer Ausgestaltung bestimmter Methoden, Umfragen anzugehen, die eben gesellschaftsrelevant sind. Das heißt also eher jetzt nicht zu sagen, wir lehnen das Establishment irgendwie ab, aber auch wieder zu sagen, gerade Geistes- und Naturgeschichtliches hat eine unglaubliche Bandbreite und Vielfalt gegeben von Formen, mit denen man über Probleme nachdenken kann und diese Vielfalt auch wieder fruchtbar zu machen. Ohne uns jetzt eben zum Beispiel einer bestimmten Standardisierung zu beugen oder einer bestimmten Art der Erfolgsmessung von Publikationen beispielsweise.
Wenn man jetzt anders sein will und man möchte sich gründen, hat man es natürlich dann trotzdem mit der Rechtslage erst mal zu tun. Und die sagt ja wahrscheinlich, Hochschule das sieht genau so und so und so aus und wenn man so was haben will, dann muss man genau allen diesen was weiß ich wie vielen Paragraphen auch entsprechen. Was ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch schon eine ganze Menge Struktur vorgibt. Was ist das denn jetzt überhaupt für ein Prozess, wann wurde der jetzt eigentlich eingeleitet? Wann war sozusagen der Zeitpunkt gekommen, wo so ein Beschluss da war und es auch eine kritische Masse an Menschen gab, die gesagt hat, okay wir probieren das jetzt einfach mal?
Also die ersten Gespräche mit dem Land, was ja dann diese staatliche Anerkennung aussprechen muss, so Ende 2013 geführt. Und das Ganze führt tatsächlich auf ein sehr interessantes bildungspolitisches Feld. In allen Ländergesetzen sind private Hochschulen, die Gründung von privaten Hochschulen erlaubt und sie sind an bestimmtem Voraussetzungen gebunden, die interessanterweise gar nicht so viele Paragraphen sind. Also in Rheinland-Pfalz ist das der Anerkennungsparagraph, gerade einer, und der hat sieben Unterpunkte. Ist also erstaunlich schlank gehalten, zumindest erst mal in der Theorie und mittlerweile ist aber natürlich diese ganze Frage, wer darf bilden, wer darf akademische Lehre betreiben, ein hoch umstrittenes. Wo es schlicht und ergreifend auch um Zutrittsbeschränkungen geht. Und es ist eine ganze Armee hätte ich jetzt fast gesagt, eine ganze Gruppe von unterschiedlichen Institutionen damit beschäftigt, dem Staat zu helfen, diese Entscheidungen zu treffen.
Bzw. ihm auch zu sagen, wer diese Entscheidung treffen soll. In Deutschland sind es die Akkreditierungsagenturen, die jetzt gerade mit dem Bundesverfassungsgericht, die haben ja gesagt, diese ganze Akkreditiererei ist da vielleicht nicht so dasjenige, was gebraucht wird. Das wird sich also wahrscheinlich verändern müssen. Aber bei uns waren es die Akkreditierungsagenturen, die sind privat. Die gucken sich die Studiengänge an, ob die richtig modularisiert sind und die richtigen Ziele und die richtige Berufsfertigkeit und alles möglich haben. Und dann wird heute noch in den allermeisten Fällen oder in nahezu allen Fällen, der Wissenschaftsrat noch angerufen. Das ist so ein eher auf Bundesebene aufgehängtes Gremium, was alle Länder berät, und das wird dann eben auch noch angefragt. Und die selber wieder die neuen Kataloge sprechen dann nicht mehr von sieben Prüfpunkten, sondern von ungefähr 50 Prüfpunkten, wo man sozusagen überall was dazu zu sagen hat. Und das macht es sozusagen relativ kompliziert.
Insgesamt ist es aber noch ein Verfahren, das ja grundgesetzlich geschützt ist, eben durch die Freiheit von Wissenschaft, also Freiheit von Forschung und Lehre, Freiheit von Wissenschaft, die auch immer die institutionelle Wissenschaftsfreiheit ist. Also nicht nur die Freiheit, was darf ich als Individuum machen und schützt mich der Staat vor meiner Universität oder vor meinen Kollegen oder vor der Öffentlichkeit, es ist auch ein Schutz, also staatsabwehrgerichtet nennt man das, das ist ein Schutz gegen den Staat. Wissenschaft betreiben zu dürfen, auch in Strukturen außerhalb des Staates, und das haben wir eben auch stark gemacht. Die Sache, es geht um die Frage, wie dürfen sich Menschen zusammenschließen, um eben auch diese Bildung zu betreiben. Richtig ist, dass ohne staatliche Anerkennung keine Hochschule möglich ist. Also man darf den Namen noch nicht mal führen. Und das heißt nicht, dass man nicht Wissenschaft also Forschung machen darf, sondern es geht um die Frage der Lehre. Also kein Studiengang wird angeboten von einer nicht staatlich anerkannten Hochschule.
Also forschen dürfte man sozusagen gleich ohne Anerkennung.
Genau also auch die Kueser-Akademie ist ja auch in diesem Sinne irgendwie staatlich anerkannt. Da würde man wahrscheinlich eher sagen, da regelt der Markt. Wenn die keine Gelder kriegen und so weiter.
Aber in dem Moment, wo man dann quasi wirklich auch Studierende annehmen möchte und Ausbildungsversprechen machen möchte und Abschlüsse vor allem anerkannte Abschlüsse sozusagen in den Raum stellt, in dem Moment muss man dann eben Kriterien entsprechen. Was sind dann so Kriterien, denen man dann entsprechen muss?
Ganz klares Kriterium, was leider immer wieder missachtet worden ist und deswegen ja auch zu einer Diskreditierung der privaten Hochschulen meines Erachtens völlig zu recht geführt hat ist, sie müssen ein Finanzkonzept so vorlegen, dass die Studierenden, die sich an einem bestimmten Tag einschreiben, auch zu Ende studieren können. Also die Studierenden können ja nicht wissen, wenn man jetzt irgendwie ganz tolle Werbung macht und die finden das ganz toll und die alternative Hochschule, die können ja überhaupt nicht absehen, ob wir die Finanzen haben, um diese Studiengänge auch durchzutragen. Das sind also ganz klare Vorgaben. Wir haben eine große Ausfallbürgschaft. Das heißt wenn wir den Laden dicht machen müssen, dann kommt ein Dritter und zahlt das so lange, bis diese Studiengänge fertig sind. Dann haben die Studierenden immer noch einen Imageverlust, aber sie haben nicht irgendwie diesen Zeitverlust, sondern sie können auf jeden Fall zu Ende studieren. Das sind also Sachen, die völlig klar sind. Dann gibt es Fragen, was ich schon andeutete, dass eine Hochschule in Deutschland ja eine Trägerstruktur braucht. Und das trotzdem die Freiheit von Wissenschaft gewährleistet bleibt.
Also dass man jetzt nicht zum Beispiel einen Träger, ich möchte jetzt keine Namen nennen, aber nicht ein großes Unternehmen darunter setzt und die einfach komplett die Studiengänge und die Forschung sozusagen bestimmen, dass alles nur noch Auftragslehre, Auftragsforschung ist. Und da ist auch der Wissenschaftsrat ausgebildet, solche Sachen eben zu sehen.
Also eine medizinische Hochschule, die irgendwie sozusagen von so einem Pharmaunternehmen gesponsert wäre, wäre schwierig.
Genau so. Und dann sind es Fragen, eben auch, wie organisiert man also die ganze Selbstbestimmung. Dann müssen Sie alle Ordnungen vorlegen. Also es muss ja alles neu geschaffen werden. Wenn Sie an eine normale Hochschule gehen, dann haben Sie eine Einschreibeordnung, eine Prüfungsordnung, einen Aufnahmeordnung, eine Grundordnung, eine Berufungsordnung, Qualitätssicherungsordnung, Gleichstellungsordnung und so weiter, das muss alles neu geschaffen werden. Dafür gibt es teilweise auch wieder Gesetzesvorgaben oder zumindest Normierungen, die dann irgendwie eingehalten werden müssen. Dann kann es eben andere Bereiche geben, wo man sich dann trefflich streiten kann, darf der Staat dazu was sagen? Also zum Beispiel das Programm. Also sozusagen wir möchten jetzt Ökonomie auf die und die Weise unterrichten. Dann muss der Staat sehen, ist das ein wissenschaftlicher Standard? Auch zum Schutz wieder der Studierenden, dass man jetzt nicht irgendwelches esoterisches Zeug oder irgendwie so was lehrt. Aber das können Sie sich jetzt vorstellen, das sind Graubereiche.
Dass wir sagen, das ist wissenschaftlich etabliert, das entspricht aber genau nicht dieser Standardisierung, sonst bräuchte ich keine private Hochschule aufzumachen, und dann kann es eben schon mal, und hat es auch Diskussionen gegeben, um eben solche Fragen der Ausrichtung, wo dann eben zwischen Freiheit und Ansprüchen von möglichen Gruppierungen dann eben auch getrennt und entschieden werden muss.
Das heißt der Staat setzt selbstverständlich einen Rahmen. Wie sehr schränkt dieser juristische Rahmen oder also inwiefern schränkt der sozusagen das was Sie ursprünglich im Sinn hatten, ein? Ist da immer noch alles sozusagen umsetzbar gewesen, so wie man sich das am Anfang vorgestellt hat oder stellt man dann irgendwann fest, oh holla, so wie wir uns das vorgestellt haben geht das gar nicht, weil wir verstoßen damit gegen diesen Paragraphen und diesen Paragraphen oder ist das zumindest so offen gehalten, dass man im Prinzip jedes Modell da reinbringen kann?
Also Sie haben mich ja vorhin nach Gründen gefragt, warum man einen Hochschule gründet und erst mal ein bisschen abstrakt gesprochen war das genau einer. Also die Verantwortung wahrzunehmen und zu gucken, was lässt sich jetzt tatsächlich umsetzen, also was ist gesetzlich verboten und was ist gesetzlich erlaubt oder liegt das Problem im Moment in der Bildung wo ganz anders. Und meine Forschung ist auch in dem Bereich, was man heute Soft Governments nennt, das sind eigentlich Rahmen, das sind keine Gesetze, also in denen klar was geboten wird, sondern es sind so Rahmenwerke, Anreize, stillschweigende Übereinkünfte, Entscheidungen, die nicht ganz im demokratisch legitimierten Rahmen getroffen werden, Beratungsorganisationen und Bologna hat viel mit dieser sogenannten Soft Governments zu tun. Es ist ja relativ wenig auf demokratischer Ebene überhaupt beschlossen worden.
Man sitzt dann da als Kollege zusammen mit anderen Kollegen und hört immer nur, ja nein das geht nicht oder das kann man irgendwie nicht machen. Und die Frage ist eigentlich, wer hat das verboten und wer hat versucht, das wirklich zu verhindern? Und Soft Governments gerade in neoliberaler Couleur heißt ja immer auf so eine bestimmte Form des Selbstgehorsams zu vertrauen. Also man macht was, weil man denkt, ja es wird schon richtig sein und ich darf das auch gar nicht anders, aber es ist so ein bisschen eine Verbeugung vor einer Macht, die man gar nicht kennt und die auch gar keine sichtbare Gestalt hat.
Freiwillige Selbstkontrolle?
Ja so eine Art und das ist natürlich in Strukturen, wo dann eine solche Autonomie und Selbstorganisation nicht gestärkt ist, wo dann auch der Einzelne gar nicht weiß, wo er sich hin richten soll. Und das ist für uns eben wichtig, dass wir uns da einig sind. Dass wir sagen, so das ist das, was wir für richtig halten und wir gucken, was muss jetzt tatsächlich umgesetzt werden und was muss nicht umgesetzt werden. Zum Beispiel, ganz einfaches Beispiel, ja man muss heute Studiengänge modularisieren, also man muss die in kleine Häppchen sozusagen verteilen und ausweisen. Was eine ganz Idee einer Bildungsbiografie teilweise ad absurdum führt. Es hat aber niemand behauptet, dass man diese Module nicht wieder zu einem sinnvollen Ganzen zusammenfügen kann, wenn sich die Kollegen kennen. Wenn man Übergaben sozusagen zwischen einzelnen Blöcken macht. Dann haben wir heute natürlich schon Studiengänge, die eine gesamte Bildungsidee und auch eine Bildungsentwicklung verfolgen.
Wir sind trotzdem darauf angewiesen, das modular sozusagen abzufragen. Das heißt immer wieder, wie kann man mit solchen Gestaltungsmöglichkeiten umgehen, wie kann man den möglichen Rahmen ausschöpfen und wo zeigen sich tatsächlich staatlicherseits wirkliche Gesetze, wo man sagt, nein hier ist ein Punkt überschritten, wo wir bestimmte Sachen nicht machen dürfen. Und interessanterweise ist dieser Punkt, wo man wirklich sagt, nein wir würden gegen ein Gesetz verstoßen, mit einer Idee freier Bildung, uns bis jetzt nicht begegnet ist. Es sind uns allerdings einige Punkte begegnet, wo Leute uns einreden wollten, dass ein gesetzlicher Rahmen überschritten ist. Also das schon.
Aha was denn zum Beispiel?
Die Anerkennungshoheit sozusagen liegt ja bei den Bundesländern. Also bei uns war das Land Rheinland-Pfalz also ganz klar verantwortlich und es muss sich alle anderen Gutachten und Entscheidungen, ob das jetzt Agenturen sind oder Wissenschaftsrat oder wer auch immer, sie müssen selber entscheiden, ob das jetzt dem gesetzlichen Rahmen genügt oder nicht. Und darauf haben wir schon hingewiesen, dass wir eben dieses Recht und auch die Pflicht des Staates einer eigenständigen Prüfung, die dann ja auch rechtsrelevant ist, dass sie die durchführt, unabhängig davon, was jetzt mal das eine oder das andere Gutachten irgendwie sagt. Und das sind wichtige Punkte gewesen, wo man dann eben demokratische Prozesse im Blick haben muss und sagen, so hier ist jetzt eben auch der relevante Entscheidungsspielraum und er wird von der und der Institution eben auch genutzt.
Was für Leute sind da zusammengekommen? Wie groß war die Gruppe, die letzten Endes diesen Beschluss der Gründung der Hochschule getragen hat? Hat er sich dann in der Zeit schon nennenswert vergrößert und was für Leute möchte diese Hochschule im Team haben? Was sind die Themen und was ist sozusagen das gewünschte Selbstverständnis? Jetzt mal nur so von der Lehrenden-Perspektive aus gesehen.
Also wenn man jetzt erst mal von den Kollegen ausgeht, dann sind wir im Moment sechs Kollegen, im Moment kommen noch zwei dazu. Also zwei Professoren, die wir gerade berufen und dann mussten wir leider aus Gesundheitsgründen musste unser Gründungspräsident uns verlassen. Das heißt wir sind jetzt dabei, wir haben gerade den zweiten Präsidenten gewählt. Und deswegen werden wir in diesem Kollegium dann zwischen acht und zehn Leuten dann relativ schnell sein. Wir kommen aus unterschiedlichen Disziplinen. Also jetzt im Institut für Ökonomie haben wir alle ein ökonomisches Standbein. Wir sind als Volkswirte ausgebildet. Dann kommt bei mir zum Beispiel die Philosophie dazu, weil Walter Ötsch die Kulturgeschichte... Jetzt wird jemand kommen für Institutionsforschung, also auch mit einem soziologischen Schwerpunkt. Das ist uns also immer wichtig, dass man wirklich auch diese Biografie von Vielfalt tatsächlich auch selbst lebt.
Erfahrungen eben in interdisziplinärer Forschung, in gesellschaftsrelevanter Forschung das ist wichtig. Und um diesen Kern herum haben wir viele in staatlichen, hauptsächlich staatlich aber auch privaten, Hochschulen, die uns unmittelbar helfen. Man braucht ja zum Beispiel ein Gründungssenat. Also man hat ja erst mal gar nicht genug Professoren, um den Senat selber zu bestellen. Dann kommen also von anderen Hochschulen Externe dazu, die dann als Senatoren erst mal fungieren. Und Kuratorium, Beiräte, so dass insgesamt jetzt schon von Verantwortungsträgern um diesen engen Kreis von acht Leuten bestimmt 15-20 Professoren und Kollegen aus Wirtschaft und Gesellschaft drum herum sind. Dann sind wir die erste Hochschule, die einen Studierenden Verein gehabt hat, bevor es überhaupt die Hochschule gab, das war rechtlich auch irgendwie relativ knifflig. Die waren dann alle an der Kueser-Akademie noch in Zertifikationsstudiengängen.
Also wir haben einen Studierenden Verein, der für Stipendien zur Lebenshaltung eintritt. Für das ganze kulturelle Umfeld, der Wohnraum geschaffen hat vor Ort. Das ist also auch eine ganz starke Initiative, die jetzt auch schon eigene Bildungsangebote macht, um Studierenden anderer Hochschulen eben auch einen Zugang zu ermöglichen. Dann haben wir einen Kreis natürlich von Förderern um uns rum, die größere Institutionen, Privatspender sind auch irgendwie schon mittlerweile um die 20-30, so dass da eben auch wieder ein großes Feld entsteht von Menschen, die mitwirken.
Aber die Fachgebiete, die sich jetzt hier sozusagen zusammenfinden, finden sich sozusagen die Fachgebiete durch die Personen zusammen oder finden sich die Personen durch die Fachgebiete zusammen? Also steht sozusagen am Anfang dieses, das sind die Themen, die wir gerne besetzen wollen, jetzt suchen wir uns auch die entsprechenden Personen oder war es sozusagen, dass eigentlich aus dieser Gruppe heraus sich quasi die inhaltliche Primärstrukturierung der Hochschule mehr oder weniger von alleine ergeben hat?
Also es ist das letztere. Also ich denke es ist wie bei jedem Startup, Sie verbinden erst mal in unserem Fall jetzt die Inhalte, also die Disziplinen mit den Menschen und dann müssen Sie – und in der Phase sind wir jetzt – wo man dann eine Institutionalisierung braucht. Wo man sagt, das ist das, wie wir Disziplin entwickeln wollen und wir suchen und jetzt auch die Menschen dazu. Aber erst mal ist es wirklich eine Gruppe, die länger schon zusammen gearbeitet hat in Lehre und Forschung und die sich auch über Jahre dieses Vertrauen erarbeitet hat, dass Ökonomie und Philosophie zusammengehören. Was jetzt ja auch nicht irgendwie so trivial ist. Also dass man sagt, das ist wirklich das was uns wichtig ist und dass wir gemeinsam in der Kueser-Akademie und eben in den Feldern, wo wir gewirkt haben, das zusammen gegründet haben, was wir Studia Humanitatis nennen, also wirklich ein allgemeinbildendes Studium, was nicht völlig unverbindlich ist, wie an anderen Hochschulen, sondern jetzt wirklich auf die Entwicklung der Persönlichkeit in einem gesellschaftlichen und kulturgeschichtlichen Kontext wirkt.
Und das hat schon sehr viel mit Biografie zu tun. Also jetzt soziale Biografie, also welche Leute sind an welchem Ort zusammen. Und jetzt sind wir eher in der Phase eben zu sagen, nicht ganz unabhängig wer es macht, aber das und das braucht eine Hochschule, um sich langfristig aufzustellen. Und sie muss auch notfalls auf Personen, also nicht nur notfalls, also erst notfalls und später dann auch selbstverständlich auf bestimmte Personen verzichten können. Im Moment ist es natürlich wie bei jeder Gründung, dass Personen und Vertretung des Fachs noch sehr sehr eng zusammenhängen.
Soll sich das noch – also ich habe so jetzt den Eindruck, vielleicht verstehe ich das falsch, aber Ökonomie und Philosophie, was ja auch Ihre Fächer sind, spielt schon eine erhebliche Rolle sozusagen in dieser Gründungsgeschichte. Ist so ein bisschen der Urknall, dem hier sozusagen alles andere folgt. Aber es gibt schon auch jetzt vom Start weg auch andere Fachgebiete, die darüber hinausgehen?
Nein also wir haben jetzt die Studiengänge. Wir haben letztes Jahr angefangen mit einem Master in Philosophie und einem Master in Ökonomie, die werden jetzt fortgeführt und aufgebaut und es starten im Herbst jetzt die Bachelor für Ökonomie und Philosophie, also den gleichen Fächern, die einen gemeinsamen Schwerpunkt haben, das ist soziale Verantwortung. Und das ist es jetzt erst mal und das ist auch das was staatlich anerkannt wurde. Das heißt also, dass wir im Ausbau, wie man so schön sagt, also wenn die Studiengänge aufgebaut sind, was im Bachelor jetzt drei Jahre dauern wird, dann würden in dieser Konstellation alleine 250 Studierende ungefähr haben. Ausgeschlossen ist weder von uns noch jetzt von staatlicher Seite eine Ausweitung des Fächerspektrums. Was auch immer schon mal wieder in der Gründungsgeschichte überlegt worden ist.
Also es gab mal von Seiten der Region aus die Frage, ob wir Therapie und Pflege machen könnten, weil sich das gerade akademisiert, dadurch dass wir Ökonomisierung viel machen, auch eben im Bereich der Medizin, der sozialen Arbeit und Pflege wäre das jetzt nicht völlig fern gewesen. Auch von der philosophischen Ausrichtung wäre das nicht fern gewesen. Es hatte sich dann aus ganz unterschiedlichen Gründen irgendwie zerschlagen und das wird auf jeden Fall eine wichtige Arbeit der nächsten Jahre sein, was passt jetzt? Also ist das noch ein politischer Studiengang oder ist es einer für Journalisten, oder was auch immer das dann sein kann. Aber es ist jetzt erst mal tatsächlich eine Hochschule, die sich in Ökonomie und Philosophie spezialisiert hat. Abgesehen davon, dass wir gerade die Ökonomie selber eben wieder auf ihren Gegenstandsbereich fokussieren wollen. Also nicht mehr sagen, Ökonomie heißt, eben eine bestimmte Weltsicht irgendwie zu pflegen, sondern Ökonomie heißt, auf Wirtschaftsfragen aus verschiedenen Perspektiven zu gucken, so dass wir natürlich Soziologen, Kulturhistoriker und so weiter von Vornherein dabei haben.
Gut jetzt ist das Personal zusammen, zumindest so für den Start, fehlen noch die Studierenden, wo kommen die denn her? Wer fühlt sich diesem Projekt hinzugezogen und was sind auch so Ihre eigenen Vorstellungen davon, wen Sie eigentlich gerne an dieser Hochschule sehen würden? Also gibt es in irgendeiner Form ein Auswahlprogramm? Wie ist sozusagen der erste Schritt hin zu einer ersten Generation Studierender der Hochschule dann konkret abgelaufen?
Also jetzt beim Bachelor sind wir interessanterweise genau noch dabei, also weil der erst im Herbst startet. Im Musterbereich ist es auch, dass sich das noch entwickelt. Ich glaube jeder Pionierjahrgang ist irgendwie anders und die nachfolgenden gestalten sich dann auch nochmals ein bisschen um.
Also mit Master ging es los?
Mit Master ging es los.
Klingt jetzt erst mal verdrehte Welt mäßig.
Ja ist ein bisschen verdrehte Welt, aber hat genau den Anlass, Master entstehen eigentlich immer aus bestimmten Forschungszusammenhängen, mehr jetzt als die Bachelor und ist auch immer die Frage, auch dann der Behörden gewesen, mit was könnt ihr tatsächlich anfangen? Also wir sind im Mai staatlich anerkannt, im Oktober sollen die Studierenden da stehen. Wo kennt man die Leute, wo kennen einen die Leute schon? Das war tatsächlich im Musterbereich. Und in der Ökonomie ist das Ganze verhältnismäßig einfach, weil es seit 2008/09 eine sehr große Studierendenbewegung gibt. Die sich heute im Netzwerk plurale Ökonomik zusammengefunden hat und die ganz stark die Lehre an den standardisierten Hochschulen sozusagen kritisiert. So dass wir in diesem Bereich einfach bekannt sind und auch als einer der wichtigen Alternativen wahrgenommen werden.
Das heißt da gab es schon ein sehr großes Interesse daran, sozusagen diese Basislehre, die alle schon genossen haben, dann zumindest im Rahmen eines Masterstudiengangs auf eine andere Art und Weise durchzuführen?
Genau und das ist eine der wichtigen Sache, die wir also auch pflegen, dass viele uns gesagt haben, sie sind nach dem Abitur zum Beispiel ins Ausland gegangen, es sind viele die im Ausland bei uns waren. Die dann mit Fragen von Armut, von Ungerechtigkeit, von Umweltzerstörung konfrontiert worden sind, wirklich große Fragen hatten. Merken, das hat alles mit Wirtschaft zu tun. Es bringt jetzt also nichts irgendwie einen anderen Bereich zu studieren und dann gemerkt haben, dass dieses Studium ihnen über diese Fragen nicht nur keine Auskunft gibt, sondern ihnen die eigentlich abgewöhnt. Und dass viele, die jetzt bei uns sind, irgendwie sagen, jetzt lerne ich, überhaupt wieder Fragen zu stellen und ich traue mir das zu und damit auch ihre eigenen Forschungsprojekte finden und dann bei uns eben auch bearbeiten. Und wenn Sie jetzt sagen, was ist der ideale Student? Dann würde ich erstens sagen, wir lassen uns gerne überraschen, aber das zweite ist tatsächlich, wirklich eine eigene Motivation, eine eigene Fragestellung mitzubringen. Etwas einen bewegt und was man bearbeiten will.
Und wo auch eine bestimmte Widerständigkeit auch einer Bildung entsteht. Das man sagt, das möchte ich unbedingt raus finden. Deswegen haben im Master ein Drittel für Forschungsprojekte reserviert für die Masterarbeit. So dass Studierende wirklich an dem was sie selber bewegt arbeiten können und gleichzeitig an etwas, was sie bewegt, was ja nicht so einfach ist, auch wissenschaftlich tatsächlich handhabbar zu machen und wissenschaftlich zu bearbeiten.
Was auf den ersten Blick so merkwürdig wirkt, auf den zweiten Blick scheint mir das sogar ganz sinnvoll. Dass man also auf der einen Seite diesen Masterstudiengang – man muss ja sozusagen auch selber erst mal ein Gefühl dafür entwickeln, wie gestaltet man konkret diesen Studiengang, der letzten Endes Ausdruck des eigentlichen Kernziels der gesamten Unternehmung ist und wenn man das sozusagen von der eigenen Forschung her nimmt, dann dockt ja sozusagen der Student auch sehr viel näher jetzt erst mal an dem Lehrenden Team an, man trifft sich sozusagen genau an der Stelle, wo beide eigentlich primär dran arbeiten und was ja auch den stärksten Ausdruck hat für die eigentliche Intention des Projektes. Und so etwas wie ein Bachelorstudiengang ist ja dann letzten Endes sozusagen die Konsequenz aus dieser Arbeit. Dass man sagt, okay jetzt haben wir in etwa umkreist, da wollen wir hin, da sind sozusagen die Schwerpunkte, die wir sehen, und auch die Ziele, die wir verfolgen.
Und so müsste man dann quasi einen beginnenden Studierenden aufnehmen und in diese Zielrichtung hinführen.
Der Master, wie Sie sagen, das sind ja Leute, die alle akademische Bildungserfahrungen haben. Die zum Beispiel durch ein normales volkswirtschaftliches Studium irgendwie durchgelaufen sind. Die anderen sind die, die ein fachfremdes Studium gemacht haben und sich jetzt über Ökonomisierung bilden wollen. Aber da ist ja sozusagen viel mehr da an Substanz, mit der man abrieten kann. Die Bachelor sind für uns jetzt also eine sehr spannende und sehr wichtige Herausforderung, aber sie hat eben noch ein Jahr bedurft, auch wenn die Studiengänge schon längst akkreditiert waren. Jetzt wirklich zu sagen, den gesamten akademischen Bildungshorizont zu gestalten, wir haben noch kein Promotionsrecht, aber das werden wir irgendwann anstreben, dass man jetzt sagt, jetzt ist wirklich ein Bildungsentwurf über die fünf Jahre. Das heißt ich kann nicht mehr darauf vertrauen, dass sie eine Bildung woanders gehabt haben, die ich vielleicht kritisiere und dann sozusagen was anders mache, sondern ich trage jetzt Verantwortung für eine gesamte akademische Bildungsbiografie.
Das sind eben die Entscheidungen, jetzt wieder auf den Ökonomie-Studiengang gesprochen, was ist wirklich dasjenige, was wir wollen und was einer als akademische Ausbildung in diesem Bereich erfährt. Das heißt also, dass wir einen Studiengang ins Leben jetzt bringen, der interdisziplinär ist, der aber eine grundständige Ausbildung mit einem wirklichen Realitätssinn sozusagen bietet, was ist das was wir heute über Wirtschaft und wirtschaftliche Institutionen wissen müssen oder wissen sollten als Bürger und zukünftiger Entscheidungsträger? Was ist die gesamte relevante Bandbreite an Perspektiven auf diese zentralen Fragen und wie schärfen wir den Geist dafür, dass die Reflexion auf die eigenen Perspektiven, also auf das eigene Denken und die Veränderung des eigenen Denkens dann zentral sind. Und auch wieder im Master, dass wir Bachelor befähigen wollen, eben wirklich sich selbst zu bilden.
Also nicht abstrakt, da gibt es irgendwie die und die Denkwerkzeuge, sondern über Projekte, über Werkstätten zu sagen, was möchtest du selber entwickeln? Was sind deine Fähigkeiten, die die wichtig sind?
Ist das eigentlich so verbreitet, dass man Ökonomie und Philosophie gemeinsam studiert oder ist das unheard of?
Es ist nicht unheard of. Sie haben heute viel politics philosophy economics Studiengänge oder auch Philosophie und Ökonomie. Was ein bisschen ein Unterschied ist, ich nenne die Studiengänge anderen Orts ist oft eine Art Aggregation, also die Kollegen machen Ökonomie und sitzen in der ökonomischen Fakultät und die anderen sitzen in der philosophischen Fakultät und dann werden die Studenten dazwischen ausgetauscht. Also man sitzt in einer Philosophievorlesung und man sitzt in einer Ökonomievorlesung und dann sage ich immer, ja das ist eigentlich die Aufgabe der Studierenden zu sehen, wie beides zusammenhängt.
So ein bisschen so medizinische Informatik. Wir lernen so ein bisschen programmieren, aber die Arztbasis haben wir auch.
Genau so. Und das ist glaube ich schon nicht völlig einzigartig, aber es ist schon wichtig, dass wir sagen, wir integrieren wirklich philosophische Fragen in die ökonomische Bildung und andersrum.
Also es sind nicht zwei Sachen.
Es sind nicht zwei Sachen und es gibt auch keinen Kollegen, der nur eine Sache kann, um das mal so zu formulieren.
Ja wie heißt denn der Studiengang, den dann man dann dort sozusagen antritt, offiziell?
Also wir haben uns für konservative Namensgebung entschieden. Die heißen also Bachelor Ökonomie und Bachelor Philosophie und jeweils dann mit einer Schwerpunktbezeichnung. Und der einzige Schwerpunkt, den wir jetzt im ersten Durchlauf anbieten, ist eben soziale Verantwortung. Also es wird dann auf dem Zeugnis stehen, Ökonomie Bachelor of Arts und dann Schwerpunkt soziale Verantwortung.
Oder Philosophie?
Oder dann eben Philosophie.
Aha aber beides gibt es nicht sozusagen?
Ja genau, wir haben jetzt drauf verzichtet, von Vornherein einen Mischstudiengang anzubieten. Wir hätten die einen Philosophie und Ökonomie und den anderen Ökonomie und Philosophie irgendwie nennen können, aber wir haben eben ökonomisches Verständnis, wo jetzt eine interdisziplinäre, auch jetzt eine philosophische Sicht beispielsweise einfach dazu gehört.
Jetzt geht der philosophische Blick ja potenziell zumindest sehr weit, kann man das so machen, dass man sagt, okay wir haben jetzt hier einen Philosophiestudiengang, der primär ökonomisch geprägt ist?
Nein also der Philosophiestudiengang im Bachelor ist philosophisch geprägt, also der hat das klassische Instrumentarium, Phänomenologie, Hermeneutik, Erkenntnistheorie, Ethik. Die dann aber eben, was man früher Nebenfach sozusagen genannt hätte, also von Vornherein das was man früher Grundstudium genannt hatte, heute nicht mehr gibt, aber in den ersten zwei Semestern durch eine ökonomische Perspektive ergänzt wird. Und dann haben wir ein drittes und viertes Semester, wo die beiden Studiengänge zusammen studieren, aber jeweils aus ihrer Perspektive und das auch betonen. Das heißt, dass die einen ein philosophisches Instrumentarium fruchtbar machen, um zum Beispiel auf ein Ökologieproblem zu gucken, während die Ökonomen dann eben ökonomische Perspektiven dann reinbringen. Also es geht eher darum, es ist eine reine, hart gesagt, weltfremde Philosophie sozusagen und gibt es tausende von Verästelungen, von Methoden und Untergruppen und Unterschulen.
Oder sagen wir, es gibt eine grundständige philosophische Bildung, die dann an Weltfragen fruchtbar gemacht wird. Und in unserem Fall sind das dann eben stark auch für die Philosophen ökonomische Fragestellungen.
Stellt sich natürlich jetzt die Frage auch für die Studierenden, wie finanziert man das? Private Hochschule, hier gibt es kein 100% Gelddeckung vom Staat. Gibt es ja auch sonst eigentlich kaum noch, aber wie stellt sich das dann letzten Endes dar? Also in welchem finanziellen Rahmen muss eine Hochschule dann antreten und welche Konsequenzen hat das dann für Studierende und Lehrende?
Ja natürlich das ist zweifelsohne eine wichtige Frage, wie man diese Idee einer Hochschule aus und für die Bürgergesellschaft wie sie sich finanzieren lässt. Fakt ist, dass wir keine staatlichen Mittel bekommen. Das ist immer wichtig, weil ja Schulen, wenn sie staatlich anerkannt sind, ja staatlich refinanziert werden. Bei Hochschulen fehlt dieser Paragraf, es gibt auch kein Grundgesetz, was uns da schützen würde. Kann man lange diskutieren, ob damals die Gründungsväter nicht dran gedacht haben oder warum das auch so ist. Also Fakt ist, es ist gibt keinen gesetzlichen Anspruch auf staatliche Förderung und wir bekommen sie auch nicht, während andere private Hochschulen natürlich …
Also das beste was man kriegt ist eine Anerkennung der Tätigkeit?
Also so, du darfst das machen, wenn du uns kein Geld kostet. Das war auch relativ deutlich. Und auf der anderen Seite haben wir natürlich immer wieder Anfragen von Unternehmen, ja kannst du nicht irgendwie dies machen oder so und so die Leute bilden. Also die Frage so, was nützt mir das? Und wenn die Nützlichkeit für ein Unternehmen garantiert ist, kriegen wir auch Geld, funktioniert jetzt bei Bürgergesellschaft auch nicht so richtig. So dass wir darauf angewiesen sind, Bürger, also Privatpersonen, Unternehmen und Stiftungen zu gewinnen für diese Idee freie Bildung. Uns ist das bis jetzt äußerst erfolgreich gelungen. Wir haben die ganze Gründungsphase ohne einen Cent Schulden überstanden. Also wir sind ja gemeinnützig tätig, wir brauchen also auch keine Gewinne zu machen. Wir sind eine unselbständige Stiftung, größtenteils eine Verbrauchsstiftung, somit dass wir keinen Millionen Kapitalstock so hätten, sondern man kann es sich eigentlich vorstellen wie so einen Verein, also man muss das erwirtschaften pro Jahr, was man wieder ausgibt.
Und das sollte eine Perspektive haben, weil ich ja sagte, die Studenten brauchen ja die Sicherheit, dass das auch weitergeht. Und im Moment sind wir dabei, aus dieser Gründungsphase hinaus, Bürgerstiftungen und Organisationen, auch Unternehmen, wenn sie es freigeben natürlich, also nicht an einen Zweck koppeln, für diese Finanzierung der Hochschule zu gewinnen. Das also auf ein dauerhaftes bürgerliches Fundament zu stellen. Das ist jetzt also gerade die Herausforderung, die wir haben. Und in diesem sagen wir immer, also auch die Studierenden sind über diese Studienbeiträge aufgerufen, einen Teil dieser bürgerschaftlichen Finanzierung eben aufzubringen. Und wir versuchen, die Studiengebühren im Vergleich zu anderen Privathochschulen sowieso deutlich moderat zu halten, aber wir sind nicht fähig, sie wie bei staatlichen Hochschulen auf Null sozusagen abzusenken.
Welche Motivationen haben denn diese Stiftungen und privaten Förderer gehabt, hier in dieses Finanzierungsmodell mit einzuzahlen? War es schwierig, die zu gewinnen von der Idee?
Wahrscheinlich hat man, vielleicht ist es auch Anfängerglück, ich habe es nicht als so schwierig empfunden. Also jetzt vielleicht wieder den institutionellen Schritt zu machen und zu erklären, eine Hochschule wird nie groß. Also es ist nicht nur der Anfang, der finanziert werden muss, sondern wenn wir nicht wollen, dass es vom Portmonee der Studenten und deren Eltern abhängig ist, wir brauchen jedes Jahr dieses Geld, dann werden wir darüber jetzt irgendwie reden müssen. Es sind Stiftungen, die besorgt sind über den Zustand der Bildung und es sind auch mit kleineren Spenden, oder größeren teilweise, mittelständische Unternehmen dabei oder unternehmensnahe Stiftungen und Bürger, die merken, dass das was man ihnen versprochen hat mit Bologna, dass sie mittlerweile die ersten Leute haben, also sich bewerben und denen zum Beispiel bestimmte Persönlichkeitsaspekte fehlen. Also eine Frage von Engagement, von Aufnahmefähigkeit, von Kreativität.
Und die verstehen, dass sie sagen, sie können uns jetzt nicht wieder vorschreiben, was sie da eigentlich brauchen, sondern es braucht eine Freiheit des Akademischen, um wieder überhaupt kreative, schöpferische Menschen zu bilden. Unternehmen selber, die besorgt sind über den Zustand der Wirtschaft, beispielsweise die Zunahme der Frage der Dominanz der Finanzmärkte, was mittelständische Unternehmen auch nicht besonderen sozusagen beruhigend finden und selber auch merken, eigentlich haben sie gerade Gründe, eine soziale und eine ethische Perspektive reingebracht. Also sie verspüren eine Verantwortung für Mitarbeiter, beispielsweise für den Standort, für die Region und jetzt in der ganzen Frage Unternehmensnachfolge auch wieder sagen, welchen jungen Leuten soll ich das eigentlich übergeben können? Und dann sind es natürlich Stiftungen, die selber Bildung als Zweck von Vornherein haben, die dann Stiftungsprofessuren übernehmen, die also das Geschäft sozusagen irgendwie verstehen.
Dann sind es Unternehmer aus der Region, vielleicht auch mit kleineren Beträgen, aber sehr konstant über Jahre, also monatlich hinweg, die dabei sind. Also wo wir sagen, oder aus dem was wir erlebt haben sagen, dass eigentlich eine bürgerschaftliche Finanzierung oder Finanzierung aus der Bürgerschaft, wie unter einem Stichwort 1000 mal 1000 also sehr gut möglich ist. Sozusagen eine Grundfinanzierung dieser Hochschule kann durch ein breites Fundament, sinnbildliches gesprochen, von 1000 Leuten, die 1000 Euro im Jahr geben, auch sichergestellt werden.
Wie viel bleibt dann für die Studierenden noch über? Was müssen die noch tragen, und wie groß muss man sich jetzt überhaupt so ein Budget einer solchen Hochschule vorstellen?
Also man macht praktisch immer einen Etat für die Lehre. Also was braucht man an Professoren, was braucht man an Räumen und so weiter und dann gibt es so einen Forschungsetat, der sozusagen ausgegliedert, so dass man auch eine Art Minderorganisation hat für den Kern. Wenn im Vollausbau, wenn alle Studierenden da sind und wir Kollegen, die für die Studiengänge verantwortlich sind und alle Räume, dann werden wir ungefähr um die 2 Millionen brauchen.
Pro Jahr?
Pro Jahr. So dass wir jetzt sagen, also wenn man mit so einem 1000 mal 1000, dass man sagt, es gibt so eine Grundfinanzierung, die einfach eine breite gesellschaftliche Basis hat, da wäre dann davon die Hälfte da. Dann haben wir Stiftungsprofessuren drin, dann hat man eben Projekte, einzelne Forschungsprojekte oder Evaluationsprojekte oder was auch immer, die auf die Bildung gehen, Erstellung von Lehrmaterialien. Wir haben sehr viele Anfragen, könnt ihr das was ihr macht nicht nur für 25 Leute im Jahrgang machen, sondern kann das in die Gesellschaft raus? Also weiter an Bildungsangebote und so was. Und den Beitrag der Studierenden, das müssen wir sehen, da sind wir auch gerade wieder in der Diskussion, deswegen nenne ich hier auch keine konkreten Zahlen.
Steht noch nicht fest?
Also es steht fest und es steht auch auf der Homepage und wir überlegen gerade Änderungen vorzunehmen, um eben noch deutlicher auf dieses bürgerschaftliche Engagement zu setzen und das deutlich nochmal abzusenken. Das ist jetzt gerade in der Entscheidung, also wir sind jetzt beim Bachelor schon bereits bei unter 500 Euro und es geht jetzt die Überlegung, das nochmal deutlich Richtung was von 300 Euro zu senken.
Pro Monat, pro Student. Das liegt aber immer daran, und das müssen wir immer deutlich machen, diese Gelder müssen da sein, vom Staat kriegen wir sie nicht oder im Moment noch nicht oder wie auch immer man das nennt und wir werden es nicht verzwecklichen. Also wir werden keine Gelder annehmen, die an einen bestimmten Zweck irgendwie gekoppelt sind. Und dass deswegen natürlich die Studienbeiträge der Studierenden ja auch für eine Unabhängigkeit sozusagen stehen. Das ist dann nur die Frage, wie groß muss sozusagen diese Säule sein.
Pro?
Das ist eine ökonomisch-philosophische Frage, die man an der Stelle beantworten muss in gewisser Hinsicht.
Und es ist auch sozusagen dann fest mit dem Kernthema auch schon wieder verbunden, weil sich ja dann auch Fragen wie Gerechtigkeit und natürlich dann auch in gewisser Hinsicht so eine Heterogenität des Studierendenfeldes mehr oder weniger davon ja auch ableiten lassen.
Genau.
Genau, wir sind zum Beispiel sehr glücklich, dass der Studierenden-Verein selber unterwegs ist und die ganze Frage der Bedürftigkeit zumindest bei den Studierenden, jetzt sind es ja noch nicht so viele, unter sich selber regelt, so dass wir da nicht mit formalen Kriterien und Einkommensnachweisen und was weiß ich ran gehen müssen, sondern dass die Studierenden es selber schaffen, auch selber schaffen, wirklich Gelder einzuwerben, um Stipendien für Lebenshaltungskosten bereitzustellen, so dass wir uns eben auf diese Frage der allgemeinen Verträglichkeit sozusagen von Studiengebühren, also wo ist die Grenze, die möglich ist, und was kann ein privates Umfeld sozusagen geben, ohne dass das Portmonee entscheidet. Dass wir das jetzt suchend sozusagen abtasten müssen. Und Sie haben natürlich recht, und das ist ja auch das Vergnügen an einer solchen Hochschulgründung, dass das natürlich Forschungsthemen sind, die jetzt wie Sie sagen mit ethisch-philosophischen, aber auch einfach mit knallhart ökonomischen Sachen zu tun haben, und man gleichzeitig sich jetzt die Frage stellt, schaff ich das in einen Gestaltung zu bringen?
Und dafür auch eine institutionelle Lösung zu finden, die ich selber verantworten kann oder die wir verantworten können.
Was sind denn so die Aufnahmekriterien, die Sie so im Kopf haben für kommende Studentengenerationen? Wie bewirbt man sich, was ist sozusagen das Modell? Also derzeit könnte ich einschätzen, gibt es noch eine hohe klare Kompatibilität, Masterstudiengänge bieten sich an, Studenten haben auch schon sagen wir mal sehr in diese Richtung dann auch selbst gearbeitet. So dass das sozusagen dann auch gut ablesbar ist, dass das hier gut zusammenpasst, also die Auswahl der Studierenden könnte ich mir vorstellen fällt in der Phase noch leichter, als wenn man sozusagen Neulinge aufnimmt und dann überhaupt erst mal versucht herauszufinden, okay was sind denn sozusagen unsere Auswahlkriterien? Gibt es überhaupt mehr Bewerber als man Posten hat, das ist natürlich eine andere Frage.
Genau, es ist also deutlich die Botschaft, dass wir Studierende suchen, also auch in allen Studiengängen. Oft denkt man irgendwie, Gott die nehmen ja sowieso nur so wenige, also wir nehmen nur 20-25 im Jahrgang und es ist jetzt nicht so, dass wir die doppelte oder dreifache Bewerberzahl oder so was hätten. Und es ist auch schon im Master was was wir beobachten. Im Moment wählen wir gar nicht so sehr aus. Also es kann mal formale Kriterien geben, aber wir beobachten eine sehr schöne Entwicklung, dass die Studierenden sich das wirklich überlegen. Also Studierende müssen ja ein Motivationsschreiben schreiben, dann haben sie ganz unterschiedliche Motivation zu uns zu kommen, aber sie haben sich das sehr gut überlegt und sie sind ziemlich gut informiert. Also haben was gelesen, haben andere Studenten kennengelernt, sie waren auf unseren Informationstagen.
Podcast gehört.
Podcast gehört und das finde ich spannend. Also jetzt auch im Master, es sind ja keineswegs nur Leute, die jetzt irgendwie aus dem Netzwerk plurale Ökonomik kommen oder vorher VWL studiert haben und völlig frustriert sind. Ich hatte jetzt eine Bewerbung von jemandem, der schon älter ist, 20-30 soziale Arbeit macht und hat gesagt, das ist so ein Bereich, wo die Ökonomisierung so stark ist, ich muss das verstehe. Also sein Ziel ist ein eigenes Projekt zu machen, auch mit einer alternativen Finanzierung. Und er sagt, er möchte wissen, was es kulturgeschichtlich mal gegeben hat, in der Frage siehe Nikolaus von Cues mit dem Stift und dann mit uns genau mit der Frage gekommen ist und dann auch wirklich ein Forschungsprogramm sozusagen hatte und sagt, passt das jetzt? Und könnt ihr mir die Frage von Ökonomisierung und wie weit kann ich jetzt in diese ökonomische Theorie einsteigen, um wirklich zu verstehen, was in meinem Bereich passiert? Wir haben Maschinenbauer, der bei uns angefangen hat, der sich eben mit Degrowth-Fragen beschäftigt. Also Alternativen zu Wachstum.
Und gemerkt hat, es gibt eine technologische Komponente, hat er auch schon in seiner Bachelorarbeit und so weiter bearbeitet und sagte, es sind aber immer wieder die ökonomischen Fragen, die da reinkommen und dass sie das verstehen wollen. Wir haben eine Commons-Aktivistin, die Silke Helfrich, die bei uns studiert, auch relativ bekannt ist und die auch gesagt hat, sie hat diesen ganzen Kurs gemacht oder macht sie jetzt auch noch, um wirklich auch die Argumente der anderen Seite zu kennen und zu verstehen und darauf auch Antworten geben zu können. Also auch da sind ganz heterogene Ansätze. Bei den Bacheloren sind es wie ich sagte einige, die direkt nach dem Abitur irgendwie mit Fragen kommen, mit einem Interesse an Wirtschaft und merken, irgendwie ja diese ganzen Modelle und diese ganze Mathematik an anderen Hochschulen, das ist irgendwie nicht das was sie brauchen. Das sind aber auch wieder welche, die im Ausland gewesen sind und die sich brennend für Wirtschaftsfragen in einem sehr kritischen Sinne eben interessieren.
Und sich jetzt fragen, normales BWL-/VWL-Studium ist es das oder trauen sie das den etablierten Institutionen sozusagen zu.
Die vielleicht in Spanien, vielleicht in Griechenland Erfahrungen gesammelt haben?
Ja wir haben einen Studenten, war ja in den Semesterferien und wir haben ja dann aber auch viel mit gesprochen, es hat auch Einfluss auf eine seiner Seminararbeiten gehabt, der in Idomeni gewesen ist und dort geholfen hat und Suppe verteilt.
Also in dieser griechischen Grenzstadt zu Mazedonien, wo große Flüchtlingslager entstanden sind, ohne geplant gewesen zu sein.
Und dann eben auch ein wirkliches gesellschaftliches Engagement dann eben von den Studierenden dann ausgeht. Also von daher haben wir schon die Idee von jemandem, der sich bilden möchte, der sich mit Realität auseinandersetzen möchte, der offen ist für verschiedene Perspektiven, aber ich wirklich die Überzeugung mittlerweile habe, dass sich Menschen oder junge Leute das suchen und von sich aus sozusagen dazu kommen. Ich meine Bernkastel-Kues ist jetzt auch nicht die Weltstadt, um das mal so zu sagen. Wir haben 7000 Einwohner und man stolpert nicht sozusagen so bei uns vorbei.
Man geht da auch nicht hin wegen der coolen Clubszene.
Nein nicht unbedingt, die ja dann von den Studierenden entstehen kann. Kann ja sozusagen alles machen. Was da vielleicht noch wichtig ist, wenn man von den Entscheidungen von Studierenden spricht, wir sind ja bei einigen Sachen so ein bisschen ungewöhnlich. Wir haben auch die Art des Studiums umgestellt, es ist ein Vollzeitstudium, wie an anderen Hochschulen auch. Wir unterrichten aber alles in Blockseminaren. Das heißt also, Studierende können in Köln oder in Berlin oder wir haben auch welche in der Schweiz und den Niederlanden, Skandinavien, also die können in ihren gewachsenen Zusammenhängen leben und arbeiten oder teilweise auch Pflege von Familien zum Beispiel übernehmen. Und man kommt in diese Provinz, um es mal so zu sagen, für Blockseminare, die so zwischen 5-7 Tage sind. Und hat dann eine völlig konzentrierte Atmosphäre, wo man auch in dieses Thema eintauchen kann.
Die Art, wie wir Bildung betreiben, wenn sich Leute wirklich engagieren und reindenken und diskutieren sollen und das gemeinsam erarbeiten, dann macht es keinen Sinn, Volkswirtschaftslehre Dienstag von 9-10:30 Uhr zu lernen oder so was, und dann am nächsten Dienstag wieder. Sondern ein Modul, also ein Thema, wird in einer solchen Woche oder in zweimal wöchentlichen Blöcken sozusagen bearbeitet.
Und dann muss man sich sozusagen nur temporär da eine Heimat suchen und ist nur für diesen Zeitraum da.
Genau deswegen hat auch der Studierenden-Verein die vorübergehend geschlossene Jugendherberge übernommen, also das Gebäude zur Zwischenmiete. Das ist hoch über der Mosel, so ein ehemaliges Schlosshotel, was jetzt komplett in Selbstverwaltung betrieben wird und nur für unsere Studierenden da ist. Was natürlich auch ein tolles Projekt einfach von Engagement und von Zusammenwirken und Studentenleben ist. Und das heißt deswegen kann man auch dahin einfach kommen.
Kurz im Schlosshotel residieren, sich ein wenig Bildung geben lassen und wieder von dannen ziehen.
Genau.
Wir hatten ja hier auch gerade auch in den letzten verschiedenen Ausgaben von Forschergeist klang schon in zunehmendem Maße Themen an, die eben genau in diesen Bereich reingehen. Soziale Verantwortung der Wissenschaft, eine Selbstverortung. Wir haben hier über transformative Wissenschaft gesprochen. Zuletzt auch über so Projekte wie Uni der Straße, also Versuche, universitäre Kontexte auch näher wieder an die Gesellschaft anzubringen. In gewisser Hinsicht auch etwas zurückzuzahlen aber in gewisser Hinsicht auch überhaupt sagen wir mal einen notwendigen gesellschaftlichen Diskurs anzustoßen, gerade bei Studierenden, die ja dann unterm Strich doch immer noch eher einen privilegierten Teil der Gesellschaft ausmachen. Wenn ich das jetzt vermenge mit dem was Sie gesagt haben über Ihren Ansatz, Ökonomie neu zu denken und sozusagen da auch eine Forschung zu ermöglichen, die einfach nicht tief geprägt ist von den bisherigen Dingen, die man immer geglaubt hat, die auch teilweise offensichtlich zumindest gescheitert sind zumindest in Teilen.
Griechenland und Spanien auch hier nochmal so als Beispiel. Was würden Sie denn sagen, was einerseits so die Aufgabe ist des wissenschaftlichen Feldes in der Hinsicht in Bezug auf die Gesellschaft und auch vielleicht ein bisschen konkreter mit der ökonomischen Perspektiven, was sind denn auch die Themen, die sich sozusagen aus Ihrer Arbeit heraus sich jetzt demnächst abzeichnen, die jetzt vielleicht auf den Tisch kommen müssen, über die vielleicht noch nicht ausreichend geredet wurde? Was passiert da? Müssen wir über ein Grundeinkommen reden? Wie ändert sich sozusagen die Steuerlandschaft? Was für Konsequenzen gibt es? Nur mal so als Ausklang hier für unser Thema.
Also ich finde es spannend, wenn Sie sagen – also es ist ja auch richtig, dass jetzt viel wieder über Relevanz von Wissenschaft für die Gesellschaft gesprochen wird. Und für die Notwendigkeit, transformativ tätig zu werden. Aus meiner Forschung kann ich sagen, diese Idee einer Wissenschaft, die gesellschaftsrelevant ist, haben wir im letzten Jahrhundert ziemlich stark gehabt. Und zwar die Aufgabe der Wissenschaft, insbesondere auch der ökonomischen Wissenschaft, Weltbilder zu prägen auf einer eher unbewussten Art und Weise und deswegen eine tragende Rolle in dem zu kriegen, was man Beeinflussung öffentlicher Meinung nennt. Das ist nur möglich, wenn Wissenschaft nicht plural ist. Und wenn Wissenschaft keinen Diskurs erlaubt oder keine Diskursvielfalt erlaubt und wenn sie den Menschen sehr beständig von Realität trennt.
Und das ist eine der wichtigen Aufgaben, die ich mir vorgenommen habe, auch gemeinsam mit Kollegen, sich dieses letzte Jahrhundert anzuschauen, auch gerade im Neoliberalismus und zu sagen, welche Aufgabe hat hier eigentlich die Wissenschaft gehabt und was kann wieder Aufgabe der Wissenschaft sein. Vielleicht gar nicht so sehr Lösungsvorschläge zu machen, was auch schon, wenn Sie sagen Grundeinkommen und so weiter, sondern einen Ort zu bilden, an dem Menschen wieder fähig werden, Entscheidungen zu treffen. Und das wäre für mich der Vorwurf, dass nicht alles, aber ein Großteil der Wirtschaftswissenschaft entweder sehr stark eben Politikempfehlung gewesen ist oder sozusagen was man Meinungsklima nennt. Also ein Meinungsklima zu prägen, wo eigentlich immer nur bestimmte Lösungen, ob das jetzt Deregulierung ist oder wie auch immer, immer nur wieder aufscheinen kann.
Und für uns ist wichtig jetzt, als das Projekt sei es im Unternehmenssektor oder im Bürgerschaftlichen oder im Staatlichen wieder ein Ort zu werden, der Diskurse strukturieren kann, Perspektiven aufzeigen kann, damit überhaupt wieder ein Fundament entsteht, aus dem eine aufgeklärte Entscheidungsvielfalt möglich ist. So das ist also der eine Bereich. Der andere Bereich ist, dass wir uns Dingen zuwenden, die buchstäblich im Schatten der Aufmerksamkeit stehen, sowohl der Wissenschaft als auch der Gesellschaft. Mein Kollege Walter Ötsch forscht seit Jahren zum Thema Schattenbanken zum Beispiel. Das sind Banken, wie die Fed sie dann auch genannt hat, also die Zentralbank von Amerika, die eben im Schatten stehen. Also das heißt im Schatten der öffentlichen Aufmerksamkeit, die agieren können, ohne dass man bis 2008/09 wusste, wie groß ist eigentlich irgendwie dieser Sektor.
Jetzt hat man das ja mit diesen ganzen Offshore-Geschichten dann nochmal in einem anderen Bereich abgedeckt und zu sagen, wie können wir überhaupt wieder empirisch und methodisch daran überhaupt forschen, dass wir wissen, wer eigentlich hier Hauptentscheidungen in der Wirtschaft überhaupt trägt. Und was sind Möglichkeiten in einer globalisierten Wirtschaft überhaupt von staatlichen Regulierungen und was ist da möglich? Also konsequent Felder zu beleuchten, die nicht oder wo sonst nicht allzu viel drüber geforscht wird. Das betrifft auch Netzwerkbereiche, betrifft aber auch Bereiche, die jetzt natürlich brennend aktuell sind. Wenn Sie sich die gegenwärtige politische Landschaft anschauen, ohne jetzt groß Namen nennen zu wollen, aber wie kann aus einem Projekt von ökonomischen Professoren, wie kann daraus eine rechtspopulistische Partei entstehen?
Also was sind eigentlich Meinungsklimata, die wir geschaffen haben als Ökonomen, auch von der Art zu argumentieren, Vielfalt zu sehen und so weiter, dass so was sehr sehr schnell auf eine andere Weise politisch instrumentalisiert werden kann, die eben auch für eine absolut erschreckende Einseitigkeit steht. Und ja das wären jetzt Beispiele von Sachen, die uns interessieren und für mich ist der große Bereich, den ich selber beforsche, weil dann auch Inhalt und Form wieder zusammengehen, eben diese Entstehungsgeschichte der ökonomischen Bildung. Wie sind wir da hingekommen, was hat das für Konsequenzen und wie können sich Individuen und wie können sich Gemeinschaften irgendwie daraus befreien? Und das ist für mich eigentlich die Geschichte, die erzählt gehört, das ist die Frage der Beeinflussung des menschlichen Geistes in einer ganz bestimmten Weise, die sich erst mal wissenschaftstheoretisch durchgesetzt hat. Also in dieser Begeisterung, weltferne Mathematik sozusagen zu betreiben.
Und dann die Frage, wie kann man eine solche Wissenschaft, die dann auch für politische Prozesse und für Bildungsprozesse instrumentalisieren?
Also es gibt noch Hoffnung?
Es gibt Hoffnung und es gibt viel zu tun. Und ich glaube, das ist was ich schon sagte, dass vieles, was heute nicht möglich erscheint, in einem Graubereich zwischen Verbot und Selbstgehorsam und Selbststeuerung sozusagen liegt und da bin ich der festen Überzeugung, dass man das als eine Gemeinschaft diesen Graubereich öffnen kann, mit Bewusstsein durchleuchten und dann auch wieder Handlungsalternativen möglich machen, die im Moment gar nicht so sichtbar sind.
Ja Frau Graupe, mir fällt da jetzt nicht mehr viel ein, was ich dem noch hinzufügen könnte. Ich bedanke mich für die Ausführung über das Projekt der Cusanus-Hochschule und natürlich auch den damit verbundenen Fragen der Aufgaben der Wissenschaft selbst und natürlich auch an der Stelle vor allem auch der Bildung, die im Prinzip zumindest an Stellen wieder dabei ist, eine neue Grundlage für ein Bildungssystem zu legen, was eben auch wirklich in der Lage ist, Leute heranzuziehen, die die Welt kritisch hinterfragen und dann eben vielleicht hoffentlich auch die richtigen Antworten liefern für die Probleme, die vor uns liegen.
Ja danke Ihnen.
Und ich danke natürlich auch für das Zuhören hier bei Forschergeist, das war die 33. Ausgabe und hier geht es natürlich bald wieder weiter mit ähnlichen und natürlich auch mit ganz anderen Themen und ich sage tschüss und bis bald.